come to the house committee on Health
and Human Services and elderly Affairs
as is noticed we have several bills
we're going to be meeting and dealing
with an executive session today but
before we do that I'd like you to please
join me in the Pledge of Allegiance
actually
pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
Chris bill for our consideration this
morning is a Senate Bill 85
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman I move an expedient to
legislate on Senate bill 85. is there a
second
representative Missouri seconds uh would
you like to speak to your motion
representative Leon uh yes thank you Mr
chairman I greatly appreciate the intent
of this bill however there were some
words said in the Committee hearing that
that make me say that we're not ready to
do this it spoke to a
self-self-declared mental health
emergency
um while I recognize that people need to
have care in those situations we can't
have a large change to insurance
regulations based upon a self-declared
health condition that goes against the
way that we practice medicine and
especially when we're looking at prior
authorizations and a huge change to our
insurance program secondly this is a
bill that is trying to address a very
very needed problem but I think that if
we're going to be talking about
self-declared mental health crises to
then open up the door for a very very
very large provision of services I think
that that's just too much and I can't
support enough for it is that broad
another discussion yes representative
Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman um
I would hate to miss out on this bill's
um what I see it as its major thrust
which is to take a
take programming to deal with the
waiting room boarding situation which is
the mobile crisis teams and to form a
commission that will study how we can
make this a sustainable program
financially and I think without this
bill we don't have a specific group
looking at how to
fund mobile crisis teams going into the
future
so I think that would be a very
unfortunate
um
issue with letting this bill go with itl
in this bill
secondarily I would say that this is
just a question to representative Leon
which is
um
I know there's a provision in here about
pre-authorization requirements for
emergency care
but I'm not sure when you say such a you
know
when you talked about
um
changing Insurance
Provisions is that what you're referring
to and and I guess I wonder how that is
such a major change
um thank you for the question most
health conditions are not self-declared
they are diagnosed by a clinician or
there's a suspicion of um they're
treating the patient
um right now I could do a finger stick
and I could tell you that I that what my
blood sugar is and I could do fasting
ones but I can't self-diagnose about my
diabetic situation
um I can't self-diagnose about any about
being bipolar I can't self-diagnose
about any of these conditions I think
that a self-diagnosis in order to
provide insurance coverage especially
because we have other areas that are
talking about other coverage so if you
come in with anxiety over my ex
situation that would then I feel that
that would then have that umbrella the
anxiety over a certain given Health
situation basically include any any care
that they feel may be necessary in order
to deal with that self-diagnosed anxiety
over over whatever medical situation
they bring our job is to make sure that
when we expand things we do them within
controlled guardrails because once we've
established a position it's very hard to
say well we actually didn't mean to
include that area because then we're
picking and choosing winners and losers
and that's not what we're trying to do I
just want to make sure that our Health
Care system that is you know it is under
a lot of stress that we're balancing the
needs and I do appreciate that the
commission is an important structure I
do have
um speak to the commission sure but then
there the commission it's yet another
bill that we're seeing where it ignores
statute that we have RSA 1449 that
statute was designed so that when we
have commissions that are giving
legislative opinions and that we we view
very very we view with a lot of emphasis
here in the house and in the Senate that
that is made up of over half legislators
and not more than 15 people we can get
into the situation and I'm not speaking
to this makeup of this committee but we
can get up into this get into the
situation where
um where viewpoints tend to be aligned
towards expansion of services without
looking at the other costs to other
areas and what other services we're not
going to be able to provide in the state
if we expand one area so that's why
there's the focus on having more
legislators this is one of the areas
that probably will come up under the
commission on commissions because we've
seen several we've seen at least two
bills come over from the other body that
that give themselves an exemption from
RSA 1449 I don't think that that's good
policy and while I appreciate the intent
around around this this commission I
know that I personally can't support
ignoring our established law just for
convenience
follow-up
um can you can you
um point out
specifically where the bill talks about
self-diagnosis or a self-declared
diagnosis
that was in the testimony that
I did to the committee
so when we when those two were
supporting this bill and were part of
the drafting of the bill were asked
about what a um
what's they what meant as I said an
onset of a mental health condition
that that was a self-described
yeah I'll I'll drop it after this but I
would just say as someone who's
um used to
um
fill in as an emergency services worker
for the local Mental Health Center
um you know it was never a matter of
um individual patients
um making their own diagnosis um we were
talking about in those days people who
came to the emergency room and these
days hopefully sometimes it's at home or
school where a clinician who is in
consultation with a psychiatrist
is interviewing people and um
and making diagnosis and making a plan
for services and they are the ones that
are in communication with the insurance
companies so I don't think the reality
on the ground is about people
probably on your response thank you um
and as one response that that's the
problem around this if you think that
you are having an anxiety attack and you
go in expecting that it'll be covered
but then they tell you no you're not
having an anxiety attack you're having
something else which isn't covered by
your insurance now you're on the hook
with that emergency services bill and I
think that that's one of the things that
they were trying to address with this
bill
um so this is just part of that
challenge representative Weber and then
representative
well I I appreciate the discussion and I
appreciate the concern based on what
people said at the hearing but it's not
what the bill says
what the bill says is
that
uh
whenever mental health services are
covered
and Community crisis intervention
services that otherwise meet the
definition of Emergency Services set out
in RSA 417 F1 it shall be treated as an
emergency and what we're doing here
is simply extending the Emergency
Services definition that currently
applies to a licensed hospital emergency
facility to the mobile services and the
definition of an emergency services
which is already in the statute
requires that before there's coverage
there has to be serious Jeopardy to the
patient's health
or serious impairment to bodily
functions or serious dysfunction of any
bodily organ or part so there is
a very stringent guard rail already in
place and the only thing that's changing
if we adopt uh this uh amend this bill
is where the deliveries of service
occurs it it happens closer to the
patient and not in a hospital so for
that reason I don't think this is likely
to result in claims for oh I'm feeling a
little anxious today and maybe I'd like
to talk to somebody it's not that kind
of a situation it's emergency services
and they are well defined and statute
already representative land
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for that that's definitely section five
but in section four it changes the
definition of Emergency Services both
for the freestanding and the brick and
mortar so if you would support removing
section four which is
page four lines 8 through 15 to go with
the existing definition I would be more
favorable to support this bill however a
change in definition for emergency
services that impacts not only our
mobile service but also all of our
established facilities I think is far
too broad to do without with without
very very detailed discussion and since
that wasn't brought up in the in in our
commentary here I think that we may have
underestimated just how far reaching
this change could be representative
Weber uh but
okay I'm just working my way back
through this and then the introductory
I think there's certainly opportunity
for greater Clarity but as I read it the
introductory paragraph would be the top
part and the conditions would still
remain but I I can see what your point
is about the definition
um if you would be willing to pass the
um section four taken out
I I'd certainly consider that I I don't
know I'll leave it to other people who
are more versed in the area in case they
have an opinion but I think that might
okay all right all right thank you
representative yeah go ahead I do thank
you I'm looking at section three
and my question on section three has to
do with the makeup of this committee
um or the study commission I thought
study commissions needed to have a
greater percentage of members of the
legislature am I mistaken on that or is
representative Weber my understanding is
that a committee is made up of only
members of the legislature a commission
is made up of members of the legislature
and others and I see our researchers
nodding her head so I'm feeling a little
thank you
um the statute that representative Leon
was referencing which is 14 colon 49 it
does state that the legislative members
shall constitute a majority of the
commission I haven't counted them but um
what I see here is
um a sub the number from the house and
the Senate right is four and then
there's
um various departments represented but
there's a number of private
organizations that are there private
non-profit in some cases
um that represent a larger percentage
and I wasn't sure whether we had to fix
that or not
could I ask for the statutory reference
again please Mr chairman sure
representative Bushman with the statute
it's in
oh two C thank you yes
oh sorry I thought your passing comes
I can read it if I'm I'm a visual person
but three person I think yeah I read it
for everybody else okay so 1449 Roman
numeral two c no commissions shall have
more than 15 members and may include
appointees who are not members of the
general court the legislator legislative
members of the commission shall
constitute a majority of the commission
the term of the members of the general
court who serve on the commission shall
be con
contemporary contemptedness with the
terminal office unless they are
appointed in a capacity other than a
legislative office
so what I see is the majority of this
commission is not members of the court
so I think we have to make a change to
section three if this is moving forward
okay representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman um just one other point that
um makes me very very hesitant to move
this bill forward at all is we are
expanding Insurance mandates which is
something on principle that I'm not
comfortable with
and this would broaden it to significant
new services that are required to be
covered
yeah
other other comments uh representative
old you just put your backpack on I did
thank you
um
in this committee what is the process
for a vote right um I believe there's an
itl motion which would solve all the
issues that have been brought up so far
I believe representative calling the
role when discussion is over when debate
is over
uh any other representative Shapiro
um just in response to representative
Cushman I I'm not sure that this
actually extends cover insurance
coverage at all it just it it maintains
some kind of same coverage
um but
um
Pro
eliminates the um pre-authorization for
that coverage I don't think it increases
coverage
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman um for the benefit of everybody
can I read the Emergency Services
definition uh both how it stands and
then how it would stand with the bill it
currently reads Emergency Services means
health care services that are provided
to an enrollee insured or subscriber in
a licensed hospital emergency facility
as by a provider after the sudden onset
of a medical condition that manifests
Itself by symptoms of sufficient
severity that a prudent layperson with
average knowledge of health and Medicine
could reasonably expect that the absence
of immediate medical attention could be
expected to result in any of the
following
what the this bill does when it's
amended is it adds or set out in section
five which would be 415-5 colon 5. and
that's the one for the mobile mobile
services and so I think that actually if
we were to amend that section to me that
would make sense if Our intention is to
have more mobile Outreach but so it
would read in the licensed hospital
emergency facility or these no mobile
trucks by a provider after the sudden
onset of a medical or mental health
condition or substance use disorder that
manifests Itself by symptoms of
sufficient severity that a prudently
person with average knowledge of health
and Medicine could reasonably expect
that the absence of immediate medical or
mental health attention could be
expected to result in any of the
following and so that expands it to both
not just Medical but also mental health
and substance use disorder which is
which is a very large expansion maybe
necessary but very large and we're not
the insurance the committee that usually
deals with insurance
so you know the discussion
all right I'll ask the clerk to call the
wall the motion is itl on Senate bill
85.
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative
yes
representative McLean yes representative
Seth King yes
representative mazur yes representative
Nagel
representative pelosa yes
representative Weber no
representative McKay no
representative Freitas no
representative peace no
representative Nutter Upham no
representative Shapiro no
representative Murphy no
representative Lanza
no
and representative tell us no
and representative
um McDonald yes
all right so it's uh for
10 to 9 to 1.
okay so the motion passes ten to nine
yes
okay
it doesn't have to be an absolute
majority right just uh
okay
so ten to nine so the motion to itl
passes ten to nine
okay my Minority Report uh so I assume
there's going to be a Minority Report
on that representative
okay moving on
um how's the next stop is Senate Bill 87
I would like uh
to pass out an amendment if I may Mr
chairman sure and I'd like to move uh
move the amendment and then not to pass
[Applause]
and
if I may Mr chairman it's a very simple
Amendment so well I can say yeah go
ahead
there was a significant amount of
concern when we were discussing this
bill initially about the supervision for
the nurses who were not yet licensed so
my amendments simply adds in changes the
language to say the individual meaning
the student nurse that's not yet
licensed has direct on-site supervision
while providing Health Care Services
because we were a little anxious about
whether the supervision would be right
there and what we were told at the time
was some camps are large enough to
require by Statute
more than one nurse and we felt or I
felt that it was reasonable in that
circumstance where you have a license
been experienced practitioner on site
that one or more of the other people who
were caring for the campers could be
nursing students
and so for that uh reason if you will
permit I would move uh Amendment 1456
1458 h
M thank you is there a second to the
motion
yes representative seconds
saying no other discussion the motion on
the floor I'm sorry go ahead
representative Leon uh thank you Mr
chairman
um I think that this is great that we're
getting to this agreement here we know
that the health care shortage is really
impacting things and especially with our
summer camps we're trying to get back to
normal and the more that we can get
people in so the kids can get back to
their summer camps and get people back
employed in this profession and maybe a
re-entry for some of these nurses as
well so I think that this is a wonderful
Outreach and I'm very happy that we're
doing this
okay another discussion
so you know the discussion and the
motion on the floor the motion on the
floor is um uh ought to pass on
Amendment
1458h well that's what the clerk called
the role
it is to Senate bill 87.
representative Leon yes
she had to step out oh I'm sorry
representative Bill King yes
representative who yes
representative McLean
yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yep represent
peloso yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes
representative Freitas
yes
representative priest
yes representative yeah
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes oh he's here
representative Murphy yes
representative Lanza yes representative
Taos
yes
and represent McDonald yes
19-0
okay the amendment passes 19-0
and now do I have a motion of octopasses
amendment uh representative or Weber
thank you Mr chairman I would move out
to passes amended uh by Amendment
1458h on uh house Senate Bill sorry
Senate bill 87.
and is there a second representative
seconds any discussion
seeing none if the clerk was ready
representative land yes representative
Coachman not here uh representative Bill
King yes represent crowfall I'm sorry uh
representative Poole yes
representative McLean yes representative
Seth King yes representative Azure yes
representative Nagel yeah represent
pelosa yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes
representative uh prietus yes
and representative priests yes
representative
yeah
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
yes representative Lanza
yes representative Taos yes and
representative McDonald yes
19 to zero May I move consent Mr
chairman absolutely there's no objection
see no objections
okay uh the next bill up is 127 and
discussions with a number of committee
members we're going to continue that to
next week
um I just wanted to alert the committee
that I have an amendment to the very
first part of that bill and I don't know
if people want it passed out now or
would prefer to hold it until next week
should we take a look at it
um sure I'd be glad to pass it out at
this point sure
I think it's gonna do it this way that's
the larger one
um I I would if I may Mr Mr chairman
just state that all it does is address
the concerns about the from
representative Edwards who had concerns
about the fees that were assessed the
language was confusing uh DHHS kindly
clarified for us exactly what they do
and this amendment reflects exactly what
they do they charge one thousand dollars
as the initial fee and then every year
after that they charge eight eight
dollars a client and that has been in
place for some time and the I can
represent that the amendment was
acceptable to representative Edwards and
to the Department
I remember seeing Email exchange between
representative Edwards so thank you for
doing this you're welcome
okay
thank you Mr chairman I think that this
um is definitely an important part to
clean up and it's very nice thank you
representative Weber for bringing us
this language
um I I know that we're going to continue
the rest of the bill I wonder if um if
we want to deal with all the Amendments
later probably so that it's cleaner or
if we'd want to adopt this one because
while this is not an 86 part bill it
still does have a lot of different
moving pieces to this one which is why
we need this additional time to make
sure that we don't unwittingly pass
something through that we later regret
so I don't know I would I would suggest
that if other people have other member
other amendments to other parts and I'm
sure that Ms Dyer will correct me if I'm
wrong about this my understanding in the
past from OLS has been if only
amendments are to separate pieces of the
legislation then OLS at the end can take
each piece and incorporate it into one
whole if there are other amendments to
this particular section then it would be
better for whoever wants to amend it to
incorporate this language as well as
whatever other amendments they want
so I I don't know what people are
bringing in terms of other amendments
but it would be useful to have that
perhaps put off for later so that it's
all part of a whole I would think so too
that works for me I just wanted to uh
question since uh I know we had had OLS
working overtime last year when we had
our multi-fart bill I'm sure
okay any any other concern uh yes
representative King
thank you chairman
um I just if this new Amendment does get
added to a bigger part of other
amendments I just want to note that
based on my reading of it it does look
like it will actually change the
definition and the fee structure because
um beforehand it said that
um if basically if you're a new provider
you're going to be paying the thousand
dollars plus eight dollars per client so
your very first year could be well over
a thousand dollars whereas the new
language it makes it sound like if
you're initial it's only a thousand
dollars and after that eight dollars so
it will I mean it could very well be
that your very first year could be
several thousand dollars based on your
language based on the new language it
doesn't matter how many uh clients you
have it's only going to be a thousand
dollars so it does appear to change the
the actual definition
it does change the actual definition
which was unclear but what I was told by
DHHS is that this is the way the statute
has been implemented and as long as this
is what we're already doing I thought it
was more prudent for us to say it up
front rather than and to say it more
clearly because there was a great
opportunity to misunderstand the earlier
one as we'd all read it in different
ways
so
what's that representative Hall thank
you just reading this as a follow-up to
representative King I guess I could
interpret this if there was only I don't
know 50 clients the subsequent and fees
I believe that that was related to the
startup
s of getting programs up and running and
that after that it was then dependent
it will go to 171 no 200 right
okay all right we're going to skip over
171 we will be going back to it again
we're going to continue 127 to next week
moving on to 200 I'm actually the
co-sponsor one of the co-sponsors of
that bill and um representative Leon do
you want to recognize me for a motion
um yeah so if we have an amendment so
should we do the amendment first yes
that would be appropriate
representative of Palazzo yeah I would
like to offer an amendment and speak to
it it's been distributed right now
um
could those of us who have not had a
yeah oh did you pass it out yeah they're
coming around now that the amendment is
foreign
why don't you move the adoption of the
amendment first um
yeah I'm uh I'm moving uh to adopt uh
Amendment
1451h to SB 200 how to pass to pass
uh representative McLean seconds
representative palazzov I like to speak
to your motion uh yeah yeah uh thank you
Mr chair uh
Bill uh uh gives uh additional medical
freedom in relation to certain
injections made by optometrists but
there are some concerns about
safety of some of the vaccines listed in
the original bill so I offer Amendment
1451 H which Atlas is both of these
issues for so
in terms of giving more medical freedom
and address certain illnesses that can
cause
uh
eyesight so
we have testimonials that shingles
vaccine might be important in terms of
adolescent Vision issues so I
specifically left that vaccine and I
added another 11 vaccine so it's like
four times more than a regional Bill
those vaccines that are worth right and
have well well established knowledge
about how effective they are
at the same time
uh if you look at three EQ I'm
ready to open it up for more vaccines
but give some awaken period until July
1st 2025 for some other
vaccines where it's either
unknown efficiency or known concern of
side effects
so
specifically a
we know that uh
ah we can't predict how effective it
will be until next wave of this highly
mutating virus so that's why I felt uh
it shouldn't be in the original list of
vaccines and the the second one is
covid-19 vaccines and uh as a vaccines
that use the same Technologies
signs on covid-19 vaccines have not been
settled completely it's keep changing
certain countries like Switzerland just
moved to pause Administration and here
it took almost two years for our DHHS to
recognize the connection between
covid-19 vaccines and myocarditis
uh and uh
just uh recently a guidance for small
kids changed from two adult doses it
went to one half those so why did happen
it's either medication was too effective
or too dangerous and we know that uh
covid-19 vaccines don't stop the
transmission of the virus so it's not
about Effectiveness it's because there
are some dangerous side effects
this bill does not deal uh with kids but
for example a CDC data from New
Hampshire shows that four times more
minus date after covid-19 vaccines here
then after covet itself and
in relation to optometrist my concern is
that some of the reported
effects from covid-19 vaccines well
actually eye disorders in April of last
year as there were over eight thousand I
just saw this reported and it might be
um
because
there are some micro strokes and
we don't know there are different cities
uh why those side effects like many
people think that it's uh because uh
Spike priority and is toxic and I put
that language uh lipid nanoparticles I
saw that uh about in New Hampshire a
resident who died in Massachusetts
hospital with uh allergic reaction to
phospholipids so so I think it's
important as to wait two years and see
what's causing but another theory that
might be true and maybe not that
uh it's important how we administer this
covid-19 vaccines if suddenly a large
portion of vaccine goes to bloodstream
and in-depth in tissues where it was not
intended maybe that's what causes side
effects in some small percentage of
people and I'm mentioning it because
we are bringing a new group of people
who will be administering this vaccines
with less training that than those who
are ministering it now so
those concerns are important so that's
why I'm saying
practice on those 12 vaccines that are
known and then after this period
and after science settled you will be
able
to administer those vaccines that are in
you and have some known side effects
thank you Mr chair thank you other
discussion
any other
representative McLean oh did I see you
hand it yeah uh thank you Mr chair
um so uh I'm I'm inclined to to support
the bill and the the amendment
um I think
um what the bill does is it expands
access to vaccines one of the things I
know from personal experience when I
tried to get vaccinated for the coveted
vaccine
um I contacted my PCP because I wanted
to have a discussion and I couldn't even
get through the the nurses were
basically uh the Guardians they said no
you have to go to a clinic when I went
to the clinic you couldn't have any
really comprehensive discussion at all
this I think at least you know an
optometrist is a physician it gives you
an access and they would be trained as a
part of this so you know it gives you an
opportunity to have uh increased access
to both the vaccine and to those
discussions so I think it's good
um I did get some emails from
constituents a lot of my constituents
have a lot of back vaccine hesitancy
because of the way that kind of things
were rolled out within the pandemic so I
think what this amendment of
Representative palazzov does is it
allows you to basically get this in get
it going but some of those vaccines that
are newer and more controversial it kind
of just puts a hold on them for a little
bit so that we can get the program
established and it sunsets in two years
so uh the impact of that is is is
marginal but it does allow things to get
established and those other vaccines
will be uh brought online in a couple
years so I think it's a good Amendment
and I think the bill underlying is good
as well and I'll support it thank you Mr
chair
representative Murphy did you yeah
I I would tend to agree
um with the idea that the availability
of increasing access to um
a vaccine through the optometrist office
is a reasonable concept I had my
questions about the bill the original
bill in some of the um the effects it
might have but certainly increasing the
access to um
having a vaccine for a pandemic or an
epidemic is critical going forward
um
and it is not to say that any of these
vaccines that you have listed in the
amendment uh are without side effects I
mean every one of them has side effects
we've kept in the shingles vaccine one
of the most devastating complications
potentially of shingles vaccine is
Guillain-Barre syndrome and and so you
know it's not like these vaccines are
without their risks
I also am concerned about the hesitancy
about specifically addressing vaccines
that are based on the newer technology
the MRI technology really what that
technology did was to accelerate the
safety process of developing a vaccine
so if you are totally against all
vaccines or any vaccines that's your
prerogative but to this to dismiss all
vaccines or any specific vaccine based
on the technology which is new and
different I think is somewhat concerning
the last thing I would say is that the
intent of the bill also was to have a
vaccine available during acute outbreaks
of either pandemics or epidemics
you don't have a lot of time in which to
and the reason they didn't have this
bill two years ago is it would have
taken time and by the time that they can
get access to given the vaccine those
that could be qualified to do so would
the pandemic or epidemic could be passed
by that time so I I think that you know
the the intent of having influenza
vaccines in coveted vaccines
specifically were meant to address very
acute episodes of pandemics and
epidemics in the environment
um and so I would I I just cannot
support a bill that targets these
specific vaccines based on either the
technology used to make it and it's
specifically targeting those vaccines
which are meant to acutely address
pandemics or epidemics going forward so
thank you thank you representative
Merchant and representative Weber
thank you Mr chair
fundamentally I support having greater
access to vaccines for the public
my concern here is that which we've
heard from the optometrist was starting
slowly given all the vaccines at one
time does not give somebody the
opportunity to go down the road with a
few vaccines I think influenza quite
frankly is probably the least
problematic of all the ones but it's
going to be withheld until 2025.
so I would say at this point in time is
we're looking at trying to encourage the
optometrist to give a vaccine the most
common one that's given out there is
influenza
um however if you look at the amendment
you really can't give influenza until
2025.
so a lot of ways they're not going to
have the opportunity to
give the vaccine which is probably the
most safer vaccine to again learn how to
get vaccines and go down that road if I
look at it from a public safety point of
view is I'd rather have them start
slowly but also include vaccines like
influenza in order for them to get a
learning curve once they go down the
road I would say in two years from now
then expand the vaccine to all the
vaccines but that's my concern is that
the most safe vaccine listed is the one
that they can't even give until 2025.
representative Weber
I would concur with what representative
Merchant said and the the other thing is
words of my colleague who normally sits
next to me about sort of free market
allowing people to access and make their
own decisions and that's what the
original bill was and again it was to
create access particularly in times when
greater access was needed what this does
is it removes the greater access for
two-thirds of the things that were asked
for in the original Bill and adds a
great number of things that were not
asked for in the original Bill and while
I I understand the concerns that
representative palazzov is addressing
here I think that
people get to make their own decisions
and it's not as if anybody's forcing
anybody to go and get a vaccine at an
optometrist's office it is a choice that
people make and if they have any
concerns about either influenza vaccines
or coveted vaccines I would hope that
they would simply abstain until they
have satisfied themselves that this is
the right vaccine for them to be having
I would prefer to leave that in the
hands of individuals rather than in the
hands of the legislature so for that
reason I'm going to oppose the amendment
because I think it really guts the
original intention of the Bill thank you
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for this Lively
discussion I think it's wonderful to see
how far we've come in the last few years
that now both sides of the aisle are
recognizing the people's right to make
their own decisions about what drugs and
pharmaceuticals and vaccines they think
are appropriate to take based on the
level of data I want to address
representative Murphy's concerns about
sort of the vaccine hesitancy around the
MRNA vaccines so it's not really a
concern from what I've seen with the
with the hesitant community that it's a
30 year old new technology the big
concern is that the initial approval of
the MRI and ra vaccines collected less
long-term follow-up data than was
actually described in the original
clinical trial design and the big
concern I'm using FDA words even though
a lot of people in the community don't
use FDA words the big concern is that
that initial trial will be used as a
predicate approval to allow all future
mRNA vaccines to be approved without
their own stand-alone human safety study
so this is all comes down to a concern
around that original predicate approval
we were in a crisis it made sense to
allow that crossover and to allow less
data collection at that point because we
needed to bring something to Market so
those who wanted to would have a choice
we're past that initial crisis and so
the big concern is to make sure that
we're not using that as a predicate
approval so I just want to make sure
that that we understand that it's more
about the process and the fact that that
approval shouldn't be the building block
for all future vaccines as opposed to a
resistance against new technology and
then as far as the amendment I really
appreciate the um the how it was brought
forward and the fact that we're trying
to address these concerns to me I think
that the limited one that we initially
had as the bill does give a smaller step
into it and and I think that I do think
that we need to address not allowing
that initial trial to be a predicate for
anything that's mandated in the state or
and that we use caution around any
that's that that's built off of that
predicate but I think that we can
address those concerns in a different
way so I I'm in more support of the
under buying bill so unfortunately I
won't be supporting the amendment
representative Shapiro did you have your
hand up earlier no representative Nagel
and representative um I just wanted to
point out something
um basically influenza as you say is the
most commonly prescribed vaccine
um it's actually been totally eliminated
hemophilus influenza and influenza are
not the same thing totally different
things so I'm just curious why the flu
representative palazzov did you want to
um
so
that those things comparing to other
General one uh
was temporarily removed not completely
little more but temporary name of the 19
vaccines and hemophilus influenza
vaccine so maybe there was some issues
with original bills that needs to be
addressed
as a bacterial and it had the concern is
that it can progress to meningitis
that's why vaccination was developed but
it's not the same thing as the influenza
vaccine and it's unfortunate they have
the same word but
um anyways
representative Cushman
oh awesome you made my point thank you
okay thank you representative lonza
thank you for taking my question or just
a statement
um so I've given out many uh vaccines I
worked at Southern New Hampshire as a
volunteer for
um and so with the covid
um pandemic that we had and I did see a
lot of people who did have adverse
reactions so
um in in allowing the
um optometrist I think we do need to
proceed very slowly we um I agree with
what a representative Merchant said we
can't just forge ahead right away and go
into allowing them to give everything
out and I think they have to also make
sure that we have the availability to
have epinephrine and everything else
available within their offices because
we never know and they also need to
check with their own primary care
physician prior to getting going to the
optometrist and get doing that because
if they've had a reaction on another
vaccine in the past
they should not probably go to the
optometrist and get that vaccine they
should actually go to their own
physician and that's where we need to
really think about you know being very
careful about this thank you
representative Cushman
thank you I'll try to be brief you
touched on something that's very
important um it is sort of addressed in
the bill it's this almost the same
requirements on the optometrist says is
on pharmacist Pharmacy interns and
pharmacy technicians
um with a few changes that are with a
couple one thing left out that I'll
touch on later not on the amendment but
so the amendment is kind of conflicting
for me personally
um on the one hand I want to expand free
market access to anybody who wants to
try a medication or in this case a
preventative pharmaceutical product
um and on the other hand we've seen that
the laws are kind of tipped in favor of
quick approval of these things and
um so there are some issues there but to
your point it does require that the that
they review the
um vaccine registry or other records
before administering vaccination and if
everyone is doing what's required for
that
um the registry the if there's an
adverse reaction that's a vaccination
event that has to be recorded in the
registry so there would be at least a
cue like oh they've had an adverse event
and it's here
um and it does require that they give
notice to the primary care provider when
the when the patient designates one
um just to let the primary care provider
know that they received this so that
they are on the same page and the main
person following their care knows
um but you're you're right at the
beginning there's there's nothing really
to ensure that they make that judgment
you know saying hmm you've had an
adverse reaction I don't want to do this
um so I'm just kind of I'm torn on this
I would like to see a hold on the MRNA
um
vaccines being administered carp launch
just because of all the issues that have
been
um seen with the covid vaccines with the
MRNA vaccines in general and if we're
gonna you know approve successive
vaccines based on that it's concerning
um so I'm very torn on this
um and I'm not I'm not sure where I'm
gonna fall on this amendment but um I do
understand where you're coming from
and thank you for bringing it Forward
anyway
representative uh
there was some mixed directions I want
to state that I'm if we want to continue
I am open to change my amendment to
include flu vaccine into immediately
available to optometrists if there will
be enough support from committee for
that and if not
I think we should uh
um move ahead with emotion
okay
any other discussion or comment yes
representative Weber just one more
comment about revising the amendment I
think we took very vigorous testimony at
the hearing about the level of
preparedness and
um and precautions
that would be it would happen in
Optometry offices uh with the three
original
um vaccinations and I was convinced at
that point that certainly it sounded to
me like they would be administered
safely
as safe as any of these administrations
are in an optometrist uh office but we
haven't heard about all of the Myriad
other things so I my comfort level would
be much better served by sticking with
the original Bill thank you president
the whole
thank you Mr chairman
um
in reference to the amendment several of
those seem like they're children
specific for the most part most measles
measles mumps and rubella type things
that are that are
administered in a childhood schedule
more so than adults
um secondly I'm glad that it references
it continues about
referencing the adverse Reporting System
I guess my concern stems from allergic
reactions especially in children that
you might not know this
um
I remember very distinctly seeing a
nurse right someone who practices
medicine who did a particular like
coveted vaccine as part of the televised
broadcast and then collapsed into
anaphylactic shock
um and this is someone who routinely
works in the healthcare industry and
would know more so than the average
adult what their particular
um what particular concerns they may
have in their own health so
why I like opening up a free market I
think that's good and I'm letting
parents make informed decisions in this
case with the ones that are children
related I'm a little bit more concerned
than the primary care physician I do
have a question and I don't know if this
is the right time to ask relative to the
original bill of the chair
is is there
is there an appetite amongst the
committee to modify section three
removing covid-19 in section o
this is a complicated one because this
amendment doesn't exist but I'm just
trying to ask a question
and then including
section Q of Representative palazzov's
Amendment right and the reason I asked
that combination
we would have to go have that drafted
is there has been some reluctance to
these new technologies
I do medical product design that pays
the bill so my family can afford to eat
and I know what it takes to get a 510k
submission for a medical device I know
how long and how rigorous getting
approval through the FDA is for products
that are on the market that you want to
make a simple change to
and my concern is and and I think this
is where the vaccine hesitancy came from
was some of the covid technology was
pushed through very rapidly and I'm not
sure it was vetted as well as it maybe
should have we definitely don't have any
long-term
um data because it doesn't exist and
maybe putting that portion on hold would
be valuable so I guess if there's an
appetite amongst the committee to make
those two changes I would offer to go
get that drafted at OLS representative
Weber
laughs
I will just say that I just had
breakfast so I have very little appetite
I I I am willing to go along with the
um bill as it was introduced I'm still
unpersuaded that a lot of Optometry
offices are going to do this
I am willing to go along with the
original bill because it was what we
were asked to do but in the absence of
more hearings and more input I'm really
really uncomfortable changing the policy
when we already have policies that
include many other ways of getting these
things and different ways under which
they're administered I don't think
making things more complicated for the
optometrists is actually going to
increase access so
um the struggle for me was do I want to
extend access to the optometrist in a
limited way
and I I have come down to the idea that
yes I do
um unless when we get to that discussion
I hear other things uh but I am not
comfortable at all going beyond the
bounds of the original Bill thank you
representative Wayan um thank you Mr
chairman and uh this is actually
building off of Representative Fool's
comment um I too for a while paid the
bills um in a medical technology related
position I actually advised investors on
where to put their money and quite
frankly if I had told anybody to expect
an approval process as incredibly
streamlined as we saw I probably could
have been sued for financial negligence
so we saw something that's never been
seen before was never really expected
and is so far outside of the process
that that that continuing to drag some
heels in about including more of the
MRNA vaccines it makes a lot of sense
because you would never seen approvals
this fast but for and it would have been
fiscally irresponsive Finance it would
have been fiduciary irresponsible of me
to suggest that it was possible
um
I'm thinking that as far as as far as we
we look at these different ones I'm
wondering if it makes sense for us to
vote on this amendment I'm not sure
where we're all going to come down it's
quite possible that we may end up coming
with um with
I guess see where our position is about
the more streamlined amendments that
representative hole had I don't know
what representative palazzov says but
um if that's something where there's
appetite maybe that would be a position
um to take yeah I I would I would be
open to visit my amendment to free I
will move forward with left and what
representative suggested
um
Mr chairman could I suggest
yes go ahead once we have dispensed with
this first amendment we could certainly
as a committee I believe take a straw
poll as to whether people wanted to
proceed with representative full
suggestion and that might make it a
little clearer as to what we wanted to
do after that okay yeah
sounds good okay any other discussion on
so you know the discussion all right so
um the motion is ought to pass on
Amendment 1451 H to Senate bill 200.
representative Leon no
representative Cushman
no
representative Bill King no
representative Seth King yes
representative Weber
no
representative McKay
Representative fredis no
representative priests no representative
Nutter Upham yeah
representative Shapiro no
representative Merchant no
representative Murphy no
representative Lanza no
Representative no
uh four to 16.
they met the amendment fails four to 16.
um as as to another amendment
um let's do yeah let's do a straw poll
who is it who uh would think that would
be a good idea of what's appropriate
representative Weber so hands are
uh I believe we can do a straw poll by a
show of hands and if the question is
should I mean if you put the question to
the committee should we pursue an
amendment in the nature of what
representative hold was suggesting we'll
get an ideas to how people feel about
so for for clarity right it was removing
the covid-19 section out of the original
Bill and adding language similar or
maybe verbatim to section q3q of
um representative palazzo's bill right
to put on hold any new technology is is
I think what we're taking a straw poll
on correction can I ask clarification
sure representative Merchant thank you
represent poll so basically we're going
to exclude if you will in line 12 of the
amendment that representative Palazzo
homophilus influenza vaccines will be
taken out
right that'll be correct
they'll even only code vaccines or the
and welcome back by the way thank you I
I'm a little confused because my
understanding is this bill's intention
was to expand access to coveted
vaccinations and influenza like a lot of
other practitioners who don't
traditionally get vaccines were approved
to be able to do
and then what we're talking about now is
removing covert vaccination influenza is
that is that correct no no no okay we're
we're maintaining influenza we're
removing covid
okay well so covid which was the primary
thing
yeah okay so and both yeah
representative
I'm going back to the question that I
think representative Nagel had before
where is the
thank you Mr chairman when you look to
the original bill in Section 3 on line
um it adds influenza covid-19 and
shingles vaccines which have been
approved by the Food and Drug
Administration to adults so the current
bill allows them to administer the
influenza covid-19 and shingles we're
doing a straw poll to see who would be
in favor of an amendment to strike just
covid-19 from that line and to have
something similar to section Q from the
amendment but we we want to find out how
much wordsmithing needs to happen so
throw out the First Amendment completely
other than Q yep okay thanks
so representative I apologize
um uh um chairman
um so
because of the pandemic and where Pat
kind of passed the pandemic but we don't
we never know
wasn't covid wasn't it set up for the
optometrist to do this in the event that
they would have to give some coveted
vaccines to now all of a sudden not have
now you're saying to take out coveted
I just want to clarify the position for
where we are the original bill
for those who were not here for the
original hearing
had influenza covid-19 and shingles and
all we are doing now is talking about a
straw poll
to find out whether it is worthwhile
to pursue an amendment of the sort that
representative whole is talking about I
wonder Mr chairman if it might be
simpler at this point because we don't
see it in front of us to Simply see if
an ought to pass motion might pass which
would get the whole thing taken care of
but I do understand
the need for people to discuss other
Alternatives which is why I'm certainly
willing to go along with the straw poll
notion
but after that I'm hoping that
will have a clearer Direction
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman um I think that for some of us
the question is in between ought to pass
is amended versus itl but between ought
to pass or ought to pass is amended by
this potential that's why I said so yes
I I appreciate that maybe we should go
with that shop Hall of who's interested
in pursuing that pathway
um and then we will know what to do
representative
uh I want to add this little
presentative case question so this bill
has several parts and several
motivations it's uh today we learned
that originally it was motivated by
um by pandemic but when we were healing
this bill uh in here what the
optometrist testified that they don't
get requests for vaccine nobody asks
them if you can provide vaccine and they
also testified that they specifically
want shingles vaccines because shingles
sometimes related with a vision so it's
not necessarily that the whole bill
based solely on covet vaccine
thank you
representative Merchant thank you sir
just to make people aware of the fact is
when this was coming to us part of the
reason why the optometrist wanted to
give the be given the authority to
immunize was the fact that they wanted
to go to help out with the coveted
clinics
and they couldn't because they had no
authority to give the vaccine or any
vaccine so that was one of the triggers
in which they wanted to at that point in
time come to here to legislative body
asking for permission to give the
vaccine so they could actually
participate in the covert vaccine
Immunization Clinics
number two
there is moment afoot to incorporate the
code vaccine into influenza on an annual
basis so I'm not sure where that's going
to go if we take out the covid and we
leave them to have the influenza if they
don't have the ability to get influenza
all by itself because that's what
manufacturing Community is doing it may
in essence negate them given the ability
to have the influenza because they won't
be available in the marketplace I don't
know where it's going to go but there's
been discussion by the manufacturing
Community to incorporate covet into the
influenza because they believe it's
going to be seasonal
yeah
representative thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for that Insight that actually
strengthens my support at this amendment
because of the state legislature who
puts forth the need for an industry to
keep a separate influenza vaccine I
think that that's a great benefit to
Public Health and individual choice so
any other discussion
ready for a stop hole those in favor of
some kind of an amendment along the
lines of Representative Hull's
discussion
who's counting one two three one two
three four seven
so 7 2 13.
okay representative Weber
may I be recognized for a motion sure I
move out to pass as originally presented
to us on house bill Senate Bill rather
200.
okay motions were made is there a second
okay
representative three seconds
any discussion
I represent Palazzo
I I'm very concerned about the original
about SB 200 uh specifically
um
making
motivation for optometrists to provide
covid-19 vaccines we had testimony
that
they are not concerned about possible
side effects of covid-19 vaccine if they
have a patient with
vision issues and maybe circulations in
issues causing eye problems
from testimony it sounds like they never
asked if it was a result of
vaccine injury so and we are putting
them in a position where they will be
even less motivated due to financial and
another obligations in this situation
is so I'm very concerned about this bill
the
alleged quantity of
problems that followed the mass
administration of covid-19 vaccines
circulation related to this went up
blood related to this codes on top of in
heavily
vaccinated communities such as
Massachusetts so
I'm opposing to this bill as an
addiction thank you for the discussion
representative Missouri
yeah as mentioned previously people have
said and I am up about free market free
will all of that the deal breaker in
this bill for me is the covet 19.
um because of I mean I voted previously
um you know on a bill that expanded
access and distribution of vaccines I
voted against that so I'm going to
continue to do that because of the
issues in particular that I've seen with
covet 19. I have many many friends and
family members who have had very severe
adverse reactions to this vaccine so for
if this wasn't if that wasn't in this
bill I would vote for it that the
mention of that particular vaccine is
why I will be voting against this thank
you representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman um I am going to
be voting for ought to pass
um I am
which I am ambivalent about because I
don't see any great need to have
optometrists be giving vaccines right at
this point but I don't see any harm in
it either and I I would just say that
I'm
kind of frustrated and sad that we're
using this bill to relitigate the
efficiency and safety of the Kobe
vaccine it's it is it is already
available it is
um
legal people have the choice whether to
take it or not
um
we're not changing any of that we're
really just saying that this this one
group of people who seem to be
um
capable of doing it safely will be able
to give the vaccine as well as many
other people so
um
I'm going to vote for it thank you
representative Lange and then
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman I'm glad that we have reached
the point where most people are not
forced to take the coveted vaccine
however people who are working under an
employment agreement that's mandated by
CMS still need to take it so I think
it's important to note that I think my
my largest concern with the bill as it
stands is the same one that we had on
the pharmacist with the RSV we need to
come back and figure out how to put
requirements for Vera's reporting and I
want to make that note that I see a
representative Merchant also nodding his
head this this is a bill that um
I'll likely have more support for the
amendment that will be likely drafted as
a Minority Report but I believe that
increasing this access is important so
I'll be voting for the bill is ought to
pass even if I may end up liking not to
pass as amended even more
representative Nagel thank you
um I've had an incredibly interesting
life I've gotten to practice medicine
all over the world and places where I
did things I had absolutely no right
doing what I was doing but there was
nobody else there to do it so I did it
last I checked this is not that
environment one of my Fondest Memories
of childhood was getting allergy shots
on a regular basis and
um on every other week basis going into
anaphylactic shock and it's really
entertaining to have your throat close
and have your skin get all Itchy and
Scratchy and all sorts of stuff and
being nine years old and having no clue
that you're about to die
but the good news was that my doctor
knew exactly what to do he grabbed some
Epi threw it in me and the nice news was
that because it was in his own house I
had to stay for two hours after and I
developed a nice lifelong friendship
with his daughter who I played with
while I was recovering the moral of all
that story is that I really am
struggling with the level of confidence
that I have in certain people to manage
things like that it's nice to know that
I have a doctor that's been trained how
to do this not just taken a course and
be a basic life support or whatever and
never really experience it but actually
practice it under supervision on a
regular basis in real life circumstances
and that's why I'm really struggling
with allowing interventions of this kind
to be done outside of the medical Realm
by people and I'm not totally convinced
or qualified to do it I think the other
thing is that if we had a clear
compelling Public Health reason to do
this then I would say fine we really
need to do what the risks out the
benefits outweigh the risk but I don't
think that case has been made and that's
why I'm not going to vote for this
oh the discussion
representative Cushman and then
representative uh McLean thank you Mr
chairman
so uh I'm gonna use what you just said
representative Nagel as a springboard
um to some concerns I have about the
bill
um when we did give the authorization to
pharmacists Pharmacy interns and
pharmacy technicians to administer
vaccinations to adults and a couple to
kids
um we ensured that they would provide
proof of that additional instruction on
an injection technique and evaluation
and managing treatment of emergency
reactions
um to their board and I don't see any
language that would require that here
and it's also unclear to me whether
optometrists as part of their licensure
are required to maintain
um BLS
certification and and without it so if
anyone has the answer to that question
I'd be happy to have it but those are
just a couple of concerns that I still
have about this and then of course the
the elephant the room is that the
adverse reactions are not being reported
when they happen
and so for that reason I'm I'm not sure
where I'm going to fall on this vote I'm
probably going to make it up and make up
my mind in a second before we do it
um again those con competing concerns
where I want to increase access to
things for people who want them but at
the same time are we ensuring that we're
having a level of education for these
people who are administering them that's
appropriate thank you representative
McLean
thank you Mr chair I mean and I do have
some concerns about the bill but um I do
think it expands access and for me
um looking at it I don't think I think
an optometrist is as capable if not more
capable of administering the vaccines
than some of the drive up cattle lines
that we saw with respect to Covenant
Administration where it was impossible
to have a conversation it was really
incredibly frustrating for me I ended up
not getting the vaccine and where I
couldn't get access to my PCP to have it
done I would have appreciated this as an
alternative there will be training that
comes along with this and I don't know
that this solves all of the Bears
problem that we talked about last week
but I think there's probably going to be
more of a chance of compliance with the
optometrist than it would be in the
drive up cattle lines I don't think it
solved the problem I think we still have
more work to do with respect to that but
taken as a net negative and a net
positive I still feel that this
legislation is a net positive and so I
will be supporting it uh thank you Mr
chair thank you of the discussion
representative Merchant
[Music]
I wanted to follow up on reps of
cushman's comments and I think
the points are well stated and I'm going
back and looking at the requirements
placed on the pharmacist and you
absolutely correct the pharmacist
actually has to demonstrate to the board
they have received the appropriate
training and in the training itself
talks about basic life support and
things of that nature which they have to
maintain
that is not the case at all with this
bill with the optometrist
so in saying that I would be willing to
sit down with representative Cushman and
possibly work on an amendment to this to
be sure that those requirements are
actually built into this as well because
it goes back to what Dr Nichol who
represent Nagel said you need to have
the training to deal with an emergency
and if you don't have that training um
just because you have some certification
and so forth you should demonstrate that
to the board that you're responsible to
which would be in this case the board of
photometry that you in fact have not
just passed the course but you have also
maintained bills BLS training and so
forth so I think it's an important point
having listened to this discussion for a
very long time I think that
um
if the agreement
is that an amendment would be drafted
that deals solely with training and with
theirs reporting
and not with any of the other stuff
I would be willing to withdraw my motion
if the second is willing to withdraw the
second and this could be addressed again
at a further meeting
and uh so there's a there's a yes
representative priest okay so continue
this then is that what I'm here and
oh we're going to go back to it in a
moment yeah we just went a little bit
bringing the amendment uh Mr
representative
go ahead if I may I want to be sure
representative Cushman
are you willing to work with me on the
amendment absolutely thank you we'll be
Amendment from both representative
okay any other questions or discussion
uh before we move on
so we're going to continue uh SV 200 to
next week
moving back going back to 170 SB 171 uh
do I have a motion
representative Weber
I
I drafted an amendment uh based on some
discussions that we had may I pass that
out
foreign
deals solely with the reference to
school-aged children
and you will remember that when we heard
the bill there was a proposal let me get
back to 171 that we incorporate by
reference a definition of school-aged
children which occurs in RSA 170 colon 2
and what that definition is is uh
children four years and eight months of
age or older and attending school
and so I I several people said to me
that there was a little concern about
that because it was in another place and
also uh there is the issue of of people
who are homeschooling and who uh might
want to take part in these programs so I
thought that the end attending school
might not be particularly helpful so all
the amendment does is it changes the
language which is now youth program for
children six years of age or older to a
program for children four years and
eight months of age or older and that
way we allow for the younger children
which was what the initial concern was
the initial concern was out about
children who are already in kindergarten
but cannot participate in these programs
I thought that the four years and eight
months was just as good a cut off as any
and because there was concern about
having a definition about what we were
talking about I thought that this would
satisfy a bunch of needs and and would
not uh would give us guidances to the
lower ranges of who may attend these
programs and what the exceptions are but
without
include incorporating the School
attendance restriction which I thought
was a was not needed
so representative Weber you're moving
1455. beg your pardon I am indeed thank
you is there a second my second okay
representative three seconds any other
discussion on on this amendment
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman my first thought was four years
eight months that's really young to go
to Boys and Girls Club then I did some
math and that's how old I was when I
started kindergarten yeah so I think I'm
okay with this and thank you very much
for bringing this amendment it provides
great clarity
of the discussion representative Murphy
yeah my mistaking I would thank you am I
mistaken but I thought when we met last
that somebody mentioned RSA 170-e colon
2 actually defines that as four years
and eight months is that correct so
you're you're just taking that language
and put it into this amendment here what
we discussed when we actually had the
hearing was incorporating that statute
by reference and
somebody raised a question about using
that statute because it's actually the
definition of school age for completely
different purposes
and when I read it I also saw that it
limited
the definition to children who were
attending school and I thought that our
the original statute here that talked
about six years of age did not have that
limit in it and so I thought it might be
more prudent simply to drag over the
four years and eight months which gets
all of our kindergarten students in
without dragging over the Restriction
about how they are getting their
schooling
um I it just seemed a cleaner way of
doing it thank you let's read that
they say no the discussion uh the event
the emotion on the floor is ought to
pass on Amendment 1455 H I'll ask the
Clark to call the roll
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
represent full
and no vote uh representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel
yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes
representative fredis yes
representative priest yes
representative Nutter Upham yeah
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Lanza yes
representative tell us yes
and represent McDonald yes
19-0
okay
do I have another motion m171 yes
representative Weber I would move on to
passes amended with Amendment uh
1455h on house Senate Bill 171 I'll get
it right sooner or later okay
representative Cushman seconds
any other discussion
seeing nonetheless Clark to call the
wall
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative hole
it's uh still not here representative
McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel
um
representative pelosa yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes
representative fredis yes
representative priest yes
representative Nutter Upham yeah
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Lanza yes representative Tellez yes and
representative McDonald yes 19-0
there's no objection we'll put that in
the consent calendar thank you okay
thank you
okay moving on to Senate Bill 238 do I
have an emotion
I I believe that there's an amendment do
you have that Amendment yet
this on the amendment representative or
the amendment um to introduce amendment
1472-h to house or Senate bill 238. I
handed it out to everybody earlier
uh would you like me to speak to that
motion uh sure so you're moving out to
pass on 1472h I am is there a second to
representative Weber seconds uh sure go
ahead to representative Murphy
um
Senate Bill 238 is actually a very good
bill it um allows for a Telehealth
prescribing but it has a fairly narrow
Focus to mental health only
um a few weeks back we as a committee
passed unanimously House Bill 500 which
was allowing
prescribing of schedule two to four
drugs
um
to a much broader range of patients to
put it in perspective you know the
number of patients that are
um having Telehealth appointments at
just DH alone are now over 1500 a day
were before the pandemic three years ago
was only about a dozen a day the
satisfaction among patients has been as
good if not better than with in person
because they don't have to travel
um as a result of the um pandemic that
has increased substantially uh to where
a large number of patients now are
choosing to have Telehealth as their
preferred means to contact with their
Primary Care it also adds tremendous
access for our patients in addition to
convenience so what the amendment that I
put forward does is two things one it is
a simply a replace all of Senate Bill
238 with the language that was in House
Bill 500 with the addition of a
paragraph uh
two Roman 5 D which deals with the
consent for a minor
as requested
um uh previously
it's it's important to understand that
you know that that Telehealth is really
here to stay in that the great majority
of patients many of the patients prefer
to have a Telehealth appointment
um
many appointments are done specifically
and only as a consultation or
conversation and a lot of appointments
are have very little Hands-On
necessarily
um
the other thing is that what's really
remarkable to me is that even in a
specialty like Orthopedics which you
would imagine is fairly Hands-On
examining joints and Etc many of those
appointments and follow-up appointments
can be done and can be done very well on
Telehealth particularly with given their
mobility issues
um
the great majority also of x-rays that
are done at Regional hospitals and now
interpreted 24 7 at DH and so you can
have your whole appointment whether it
be an x-ray and then an appointment to
follow via Telehealth and in the people
that really benefit from this
tremendously and not only the people
with mental health issues but also those
with uh issues regarding palliative care
or hospice care that travel to and from
a hospital is really not only an
inconvenience but sometimes dangerous uh
post-op uh patients that have difficulty
with Mobility oftentimes all you really
need to do is check in with a Telehealth
appointment look at their wound on
Telehealth or talk to them over the
phone and say how you doing and if they
have no concerns then you move on
um and you can do other things that
happen in an appointment that you know
you would otherwise do in person so for
instance you know you may prescribe
physical therapy or occupational therapy
you may order a consult you may order an
X-ray or another study this can all be
done via Conversation Over Telehealth so
it is a blooming growing field in the
care of patients especially in a in a
state like New Hampshire which is fairly
Rural and getting here particularly in
the difficult winter months is a certain
advantage and even a safety concern for
many patients so the bottom line is that
this is a bill that we passed House Bill
500 uh unanimously 20 to nothing
um and this bill the amendment that I'm
putting forward is really a place all of
238 to expand the scope of practice of
Telehealth but also to provide some
language regarding consent for minors so
um that's where we are right now
thank you have a discussion yes
representative Weber
thank you so my understanding is that
all we've done is take what we already
passed and included the consent
provision would you speak to the
provision of the consent provision and
just tell us what it says really what it
says is that
um oral you need to obtain oral or
written consent from the patient and or
if the patient is a minor from the
patient's parent or Guardian unless
state or federal law allows a minor to
consent to treatment without the consent
of a parent or Guardian so it gives
Clarity to
um consent for a minor
with the
state and federal statute of laws
modifying as necessary
of a discussion
representative way on um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you very much
representative Murphy for bringing this
amendment
um I had actually looked at replacing
those sections around prescribing with
our language from House Bill 500 and I
really really appreciate you taking on
the consent Factor
um the as far as the consent goes this
is a very good step
um but I think that we still have some
existing problems around informed
consent that'll be beyond the scope of
this bill but I think that it's very
very important that we do serious work
to get appropriate definitions
guidelines and guardrails on confirm on
informed consent into the statutes so
that as we expand non-traditional
medicine and we have these appropriate
consents we we make sure that people are
protected in this process I guess my
I do see in here that it says that um
there's obtained consent from the
patient or parent or Guardian only once
um my only question around that is if
it's once for the entire course of
things or if you end up interacting with
them on a different
um on a different issue because maybe
you may be consenting with me about my
sprained wrist and I squeeze it for you
on camera so you know I'm not doing the
long bone fracture scream
but then we if we move into a different
topic I'm concerned about whether it be
a notification if it's a change in scope
I would think you know I would agree
with that that if in fact you're really
obtaining consent to treat a particular
problem that a minor has so I think that
that probably is the scope it's not like
once you provide a consent to treat
that it's for every episode of care that
goes forward even specifically in to
your point for a different problem
altogether so this is informed consent
specifically for the um
in my mind for the um the problem at
hand
can I follow up to that thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for that I know
that this is under a bit of a deadline
because the federal rules that allow it
I expire either May 11th to 13th so
um if if you were to write the committee
report would you be willing to discuss
that the intention is that it's only for
this particular scope and that any scope
of practice would change yes thank you
please tell the discussion
representative McLean yeah and just a
question I mean I like this because it
it takes 500 and makes it stronger but
in your experience just common practice
when it comes to consent is that how
consent is understood today I think it
is but I you know I think to
representative lands our point is that
it should be implied that it is for a
blanket coverage when you first
establish a patient physician
relationship but that if we have a
consent for the operating room it's an
operating room consent for that
procedure that day not for um if I did a
total hip today it's not for fixing
their broken broken bone two two years
from now so it is you know that's my you
know interpretation and I think it's
always been the standard of care that
any
um informed consent is done for the
procedure and or treatment that you are
thank you Mr chairman
um thank you for bringing this amendment
forward I agree it's Pro it's a good
step um I don't think that it quite
meets
um where the rubber meets the road it's
it's not
um strong enough I think you could put
in your report that it's for everything
on you know in one encounter and one
problem but when this is implemented by
you know private medical facilities
they're not going to have the committee
report in front of them and I'm
concerned especially because this
started as a bill about mental health
treatment that we will have minors who
are meeting with a psychiatrist via
telemedicine and they get consent for
that first meeting and then you know at
the next one the psychiatrist says well
we should put you on these six
medications and now the chat they've
already gotten consent and they don't
need it again so I I see
um kind of a hole there and I won't be
able to support this amendment
another discussion yes representative uh
Shapiro
uh on another issue I would like to
confirm
um and remind people that this still
um
this still requires a yearly in-person
visit
it does it requires a first establishing
a patient um physician relationship and
then subsequently at least annually uh
thereafter
and also to remind us that this is
really
you know a bill specifically about
enhancing this is not a bill for
enhancing a physician's practice it's
not for enhancing Hospital's you know
ability to care you know you know
ability to bill for patient care
these patients need to care regardless
if they see a physician or a provider in
person what this bill really does and if
we we try to get to the root of it it's
a the core concept of the bill is to
basically provide access to care for
those people that
for for who getting to the hospital is a
not only difficult but also sometimes
dangerous and again this this provides
just another mechanism in which we can
provide increased access but also
appropriate care to patients
1700 sounds like a lot of patients per
day getting you know Telehealth visits
but we're talking you know in
relationship to several tens of
thousands per day getting access to care
this would only be utilized
from a provider's perspective when it's
appropriate to see a patient via
Telehealth uh it doesn't ease their
ability to take care of a patient they
still have to document they still have
to see the patient you know whether it's
in person or via Telehealth it just
provides an access in a means by which
patients can get safe and reliable and
in regards to the informed consent and I
absolutely believe that parents should
consent to any kind of treatment
I would say that that's
kind of a complex and fuzzy area
sometimes when
when I had a private practice and I was
treating an adolescent I would
definitely get parental consent to do
that treatment and I would renew that
consent every year but I would not
necessarily
unless it was clinically called for I
would not necessarily
get consent again every time we talked
about a different issue and that um in
that child's life so I think it's um
I think the spirit of what we should aim
for is that we're absolutely having the
parents permission to be doing what
we're doing with a minor but I think
it's kind of a complex thing to um
Define in writing
representative Nagel did you have a
question first of all I'm sorry the
little dazed here
um
uh thank you very much for bringing that
up um I was very concerned about the
people I represent that I've talked
about a million times not being included
in this legislation I have a question I
think more than anything
um
so I do a lot of telemedicine for the
reasons that you said
um I would never ever make a major
change in my treatment plan without
physically seeing the person unless it
was an extraordinary circumstance but I
was kind of looking through the
legislation somewhat to the medical
board rules and things like that to see
if that's in statute but I I did not see
it do you know if that exists that
there's a requirement or are we just
talking like ethics and best practice
um I'm not aware of anything written in
statute that specifies exactly when and
how often you have to have you know
consent
but I I would Echo and agree with your
intent about informed consent and also
representative Shapiro I mean for us as
clinicians taking care of patients we
always you know get a obtained consent
from an adult for a procedure or from an
adult for the care of their child or
adolescents or their minor and that's
just the way we practice medicine and so
um you know that's the way I've always
practiced and I think that's what you
always practice and we always would do
that if we ever made a major change to
their medication or their treatment or
procedures I mean you always get
informed consent from the custodian of
the the minor
um
can I ask a follow-up
um I'm sorry follow-up sure
um so one of the things that I think is
a little confusing about telemedicine is
sometimes there's an audio or a visual
component and sometimes there's not
there's a dramatic difference between
the two in terms of follow-up care
um
should we be separating these two in
statute also and I I I'd like to respond
to that I think it is defined as both
audio and visual and I understand the
concern you might have but I also think
about it from a clinical perspective if
I as a surgeon wanted to see the patient
and I wanted to check the wound I would
want to I would then insist that they
come and see me okay I think there's
certain ethical standards and there are
safeguards you know that are you know
um uh dictated by the Board of Medicine
and by our licensure
um and so I I think that's I wouldn't
say it's at the discretion of the
position but on the other hand
you know as well you know as well as I
that if I had to see the patient
physically present to either examine
them uh check a wound
um whatever it is that requires in
person I would insist on that even if
it's necessarily not the most convenient
thing for the patient but I would do
that anyway but as in oftentimes many of
our appointments with patients are
mostly conversational we are how you
doing how's your range of motion what's
your pain level like right now what do
you need right now and that can be
handled so I I without further
handcuffing you know the clinical
practice which I think is always
intending to do the right by the patient
I would never you know not see a patient
if I was concerned about the wound I
would actually say you need to come in I
need to take a look at this so I'm not
sure separating them out would
necessarily uh do anything but add
further confusion to the bill
representative Weber
okay
I've got several points to make the
first one being that we already passed
every single thing that's in this bill
except for the consent piece
um we have had over the years
discussions about
Visual
Communications and
I think the thing to remember about this
bill is it's not relieving Physicians
and I think people have touched on this
but we're not relieving Physicians of
any of their obligations of practice
by doing this we are simply giving them
more tools and so if a physician God
forbid is using it inappropriately there
are disciplinary
tracts of various sorts flawed but
they're there
to help with that so
um what we're doing is
keeping everybody's standards as they
are we have made if we adopt this
amendment the consent marginally clearer
and yes it is fuzzy but it's marginally
clearer if we adopt this and otherwise
we're just giving
medical professionals a tool at a time
when we very much need it and I will say
as somebody who lived with a husband
with metastatic bone disease for four
years
if I'd had to drive him from my home
then in Brattleboro Vermont to Dartmouth
Hitchcock for treatment he would have
died in Year One
because he would not have been able to
take the pain of the transport
caused the hospital was 10 minutes away
we could get him there for every single
treatment he needed
but on the days when he did not need a
shot or an infusion it would have been
such a relief
not to have had to haul him physically
out to the car haul him out of the car
haul him into the doctor's office to
have a conversation
just would have been an incredible
blessing to have this in place so I urge
the adoption of the amendment I have
urged the adoption of the whole bill and
I hope that it will be concurred with
and moving on its way to the governor
before the deadline
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman
um well I I agree and I I support SB 500
as it was written because I think it was
almost better to be silent on this
consent and just stick with the current
laws as they are and in this amendment
having this oral or written consent
um and you know this clause on line 27
and the other one for the nurse
practitioners we're opening it up to
where consent won't be required for
minors by their by their parents or from
their parents for minors
um I almost I I would I would support
this amendment without d
because that last sentence for services
delivered through on an ongoing basis
the practitioner need obtained consent
from the patient or parent or Guardian
only wants we already have laws that
require consent for treatment of minors
except in very specific circumstances
and I think that those are strong and
and they're clear and this opens to
opens things up to a lot of nuance thank
you representative Merchant I'm sorry
huh
thank you
help me understand when I look at this
issue of consent
how is this different using telemedicine
from an in-person visit because if you
have an in-person visit
because this doesn't deal with in person
it deals with telemedicine so is there a
difference between what we're doing here
under telemedicine versus what would
happen if they came in person I'm not
aware that there's a difference thank
you
representative
um Leon and then representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman
um I I was looking at this and looking
at the potential to have a section e to
schedule an in-person encounter
following any major change in treatment
but I'm almost wondering if standing
with our position on House Bill 500
makes more sense if the existing
informed consent stance
so that that that is my question there
because I do like having more consent
for for for children but I I do
I do agree with representative Cushman
that perhaps this actually lowers the
bar as opposed to going with what we
already have and I without a deep dive
into this consent section I I don't want
to potentially dilute the protections we
already have in place okay
representative Weber and then
representative mazura
I just wanted to alert the committee
that
the consent provision was to
incorporate some of the Senate's
language on 238 that I think I was under
the impression that everybody thought
was good but in the event that this
amendment is voted down I have another
amendment that is just 500 as we passed
it so it's available to us if this
amendment goes thank you representative
mazura
yeah my concern too is what others have
said
um is section D specifically the minute
this came before me I underlined it
immediately was the you know consent
from patient or a parent regarding only
once
so that to me sounds like a blanket
consent
instead of per diagnosis consent which
diagnoses can change drastically and so
does that consent just one off just
blanket right through the whole thing
that's my big concern with that one that
particular line
um I I can't vote for this with that
line in there
thank you of the discussion
the representative Cushman I would be
happy to
um support representative Weber's other
Amendment after taking a look at it and
if it is just SB 500 straightforward
replacing eight HB thank you
another discussion
representative Murphy
uh yes it was brought up about you know
the some of the safeguards and you know
for prescribing medications for minors
or otherwise and I just want to remind
us all that there are multiple
safeguards in effect already when
prescribing medications not only the DEA
requirements that we all have in our
prescribing practices
um we have
um standard of care and our DEA
licensure
um we have in the here a stipulation
have to be seen at least once a year but
I'm not sure but we also have in the
state of New Hampshire the New Hampshire
um prescription drug monitoring program
which really does electronically monitor
all the medications that are prescribed
and if there's any particular red flags
they will be alerted to
um either the the provider in or the
Board of Medicine so there there are a
lot of safeguards in place regarding
prescribing of these medications in the
state
of the discussion yes representative
Merchant if I could follow up
to the issue I raised before
if this is the same
requirement for in-person versus
telemedicine why do we need it in the
other discussion
representative I think it came up
because there was language in the
original bill that was concerning about
consent and so that was well-intentioned
there was no concern in the original
House bill 500.
and the
incorporation of this consent provision
came from the language of Senate Bill
238 and I just wanted to be sure that we
were all clear on that
okay I'm representative Shapiro
thank you can I suggest that we take a
straw poll about which amendment it
sounds like everyone's in favor of this
bill generally and can I suggest that we
just take a straw poll about which
amendment people would prefer
and that sounds fine to me
all those in favor of the Quran I'm
sorry go ahead representative Murphy not
I'm not sure this will change anybody's
mind or not but I I understand that the
Senate has passed
um House Bill 500 with the amendment
that's already Incorporated here
so
with this amendment
representative
okay
okay do we still want to stop hole yes
okay so all those in favor of the
amendment before us right now please
okay all those in favor uh
all those in favor of what
representative Weber is talking about
because that would be the more popular
of the two
the more support
so okay
would it be sensible simply to proceed
to a vote on this amendment and see I
would say so yeah any other discussion
seeing none let's have a vote uh unless
the flex call the wall
representative Leon no which amendment
we oh it'd be what's the number one four
seven two eight one four seven two eight
we only have one Motion in front of what
motion is ought to pass on this
amendment
representative Cushman no
representative Bill King no
representative pole no
representative McLean no
representative Seth King no
representative Missouri no
representative Nagel yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative fredis yes
representative priest yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant no
representative Lancer yes
representative yes
representative McDonald no
so it's 10 to 10 okay so the amendment
fails no Amendment fails uh Mr uh
chairman may I move Amendment
1454 h
sure and my direction to OLS was simply
to incorporate our house bill 500 in
well I've got to uh actually he's got to
go over to the Edna meeting for a brief
period upstairs we'll be back shortly
and I'll turn the chair over to the vice
damn was that a second from
um did you want to second one okay yes
yes
oh
so I just want to give everybody a
chance to read over this to make sure
that they're comfortable and that it's
yes I realize it's um
question or proposals to raise the
committee I know it's an executive
session so I'll offer that and that let
you go inside
um you have a process question yes you
uh you can ask the process question
thank you can you push the microphone
please for the record my name is Matthew
Hood uh government relations with
Dartmouth Health uh as representative
Murphy indicated
um the Senate HHS committee this morning
um voted to approve to approve I think
it was he said HB 500 as it came over
from the house with the consent
Amendment which the chair felt strongly
about to cover the belt and suspenders I
guess in that case
uh if the house my question is if the
house sends something different uh back
to the Senate
I think do we miss the time frame to
catch that May 11th date that's my
question Madam chair thank you and that
is a very good question so
um that was a committee vote in the
Senate so they have adopted an amendment
but they haven't taken it to the floor
um as co-equal bodies if we take this
amendment to the floor we then as a
whole body will vote on it and so we
will see we see we're following the
process through with both sides I
understand the time frame and the need
but we also want to make sure that we're
making the right legislation
representative Weber thank you madam
chair the other thing is that either of
these will be voted on by of the floor
by the full body full Senator Full House
it will then go back to the other body
either for concurrence or for committee
of conference if they differ
and at that point uh the two bodies
together are in control of the time
frame but
um
you know it's it's going to be the same
question either way
it's just going in different directions
if we have one house version and if the
house and the Senate
pass two different versions
there is the opportunity for a committee
of conference there's the opportunity to
Concur and simply send it to the
governor or there's the opportunity to
non-concur and let something die and
that happens every single time uh yes
thank you representative my raising
question purely for the time
considerations understanding that that
co-equal branches can approach things
how they choose and just trying to
figure out the dovetailing of it if the
policy is in fact favorable of both
bodies Madam chair point of clarity for
myself
um so this amendment you
um representative Weber you said had
five HP 500 language in it without
though the amendment that do we and we
don't know what the amendment is at the
moment
because it just passed this morning uh
representative I I'm under the
impression that it was the exact same
language that we saw in the in the
amendment introduced by representative
Murphy and that that was intended to
streamline the process
um however what I'm seeing here is that
this committee was while we appreciated
the idea of the informed consent
um is not and was not in favor of that
Amendment so we're looking now to see if
we want to State the house position of
House Bill 500
um and if this is something that will be
adopted by this committee if it is then
that also sends a signal that this
committee as a whole did not adopt the
informed consent provision and believes
that the existing law already covers
this use case
um I I know I personally appreciate the
Senate's attempt to do this informed
consent is something that should always
be approved improved upon but I'm just
I'm not convinced that this is an
improvement which is why I did not
support that Amendment even though quite
honestly at first glance I thought it
was going to be fantastic but that's why
we have these sessions so we can discuss
so has anybody had a chance to look
through my my internet was loading
slowly is this the same as House Bill
okay so um would you like to speak to
your motion representative Weber solely
to say that it was my instruction to OLS
to Simply substitute House Bill 500 as
adopted by the house in its entirety so
I hope people have had a chance to check
and make sure that was done I didn't
because I was trusting to representative
Murphy's
motion but
um I hope this
be favorable
thank you is there any further
okay
um
I was not on this committee as a member
or a sub at the time but it does look
from the docket that HB 500 passed on
consent right 20-0 out of the house and
then a lot of the committee and then on
consent so I think there's a very well
established position for this
yes thank you very much representative
yes it did it did go through quite well
because we see this need
um I appreciate the Senate trying to
expand the coverage but I know that I'm
personally not quite ready for that
myself
um
so I guess um if we're ready we can ask
this is uh Amendment 1454h
representative land
yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative yes
represent McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel
representative pelosa yes
representative Weber yes representative
Kay yes
representative fredis yes
representative priest yes
representative
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Lanza yes
representative yes
and representative McDonald is not here
19-0
thank you the amendment is adopted is
there a further discussion on the bill
as amended representative I I would move
the passage of the bill as amended thank
you very much thank you very much is
there a second representative Cushman
thank you and thank you for correcting
my process I appreciate it greatly um is
there further discussion or shall I have
the clerk call the role
we made the motion in a second please um
the motion was made by representative
Weber and seconded by representative
representative land
yes representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representable
yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yeah
representative pelosov
yes
representative Weber yes representative
K yes representative fredis yes
representative priest yes
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Lanza yes
representative Tellez yes
and represent McDonald no vote 19-0 is
there any objection to putting this on
the consent calendar
yeah Madam chairman yes representative
okay when you're presiding don't you
vote glass
um should I be voting last when I'm
presiding that's a good question I'm
sorry about that yeah not a problem
thank you for the correction okay
yeah
objects
oh yeah no
so a representative Weber I had you on
the committee report on 171 and I think
on 87
um
I am on
171.
and I am also yes I'm 187 that's correct
so I got three okay
would you like to do this one or would
you like somebody else to write it okay
fantastic just didn't want to overburden
[Laughter]
thank you
I'm I would have to check on what we're
allowed to do for a um
about discussion of what's going on in
the other body I don't think I can
incorporate it into a
um
into a um blurb so I think I just have
to say that what we've done is we've
simply taken what we believe to be the
better bill which is already the
position of the house and send it back
to the Senate that way and that we've
reaffirmed our position perhaps thank
you
I know that numerically 239 would be
next but chairman McDonald needed to
step out of the room I do know that
there are some moving pieces on House
Bill 240 so I didn't know if we wanted
to take up 240 next to at least start
discussing before we have a motion to
understand the landscape representative
Weber would that make sense
um I think we're in the same position
with either of them but
um uh the if I may speak to 240
um
the bill as it came to us was confusing
and I personally had a significant
amount of difficulty understanding
exactly what the purpose of the bill was
because as you may have remembered I
said at the time normally we think of a
patient as being able to consent for
treatment to whatever they want to
consent to providing they have informed
consent
um and I thought that what I was hearing
was that this bill was needed because
they were prohibited from doing that and
after a significant amount of back and
forth I think we have reached the
conclusion that yes they can but more
clarity would be helpful
uh the second thing that happened is
that
there were Provisions added to the bill
in the Senate that dealt with clinical
research and
um I think what emerged in talking to
various people was a notion that the
there is a significant difference
between your consent
to
uh sharing of certain sensitive
information for treatment of your own
condition
and to uses for research and that people
might want to have a greater
um
a greater clarity about the differences
between those two things and the
opportunity to consent to them one at a
time so that you might want to consent
to one you might not want to consent to
the other
um I've had discussions with Mr hood and
various other people about what that
language might be but we haven't reached
the language yet so if if that's a
concept that people would like to
consider that's great
um the suggestion I made to the chair
was that because 240 is not an early
bill was that he appoint an official
subcommittee not an informal
subcommittee so that it had
a actual hearing notices in the calendar
because this isn't due till June 1st and
that way we would be sure that everybody
who wants a bite at the pie not just the
people that I happen to be calling would
get their say but that is up to the
chair so
um
that's as far as I've gotten okay thank
you very much representative Weber
that's a really good landscape and
that's actually pretty similar from with
the discussions that I've had as well I
guess seeing that it's quarter till noon
and that the Chairman's in another
committee perhaps we want people to
think about whether they'd want to
participate in that official
subcommittee as far as the members of
this committee go perhaps we should
break for lunch until one o'clock and
then we can um officially it's
officially open that executive
um
well it wouldn't be an opening an
executive session if this if the chair
chooses to appoint a subcommittee the
chair May simply do it without input for
many of us okay
um but I hope he would ask about
interest and I know knowing the chair
that he would so that's something that
we can do when we come back from lunch
at one o'clock yeah does that sound good
to everybody
then with that we will recess this um
executive session until one o'clock
okay back from lunch and uh
way we go so um uh it looks like there's
two bills left that at least for today
for us to look at uh one of them has
some amendments pending and the sponsor
of those amendments said to him go to
the state house so we'll um we'll wait
on that a bit
so why don't we go to everyone's
favorite and the long anticipated
thank you Mr chairman um since this is
such a big Wild and Woolly topic as a
whole are we just going to have just a
discussion about points at this point
before bringing anything formally that's
fine sure
kind of a kind of a groundbreaker or
Icebreaker so to speak
I know there's a lot of concerns
understandably so it's a huge issue Mr
chair yes representative Missouri what
are we doing with 240
uh that looks like it's going to be uh
this is we're going to put a
subcommittee together okay and um so
we'll wait till they get back is that
the okay well not we don't have to wait
on that one until they get back
oh
okay so are we done with that one then
uh for the time being uh are you
interested in serving on a subcommittee
for that one or yeah okay representative
Weber you would like to okay
okay so um and the average subcommittee
is I know it doesn't have a specific it
can be three or five
they're supposed to be in in
proportional to representation so it
probably ought to be even at this point
um
okay so representative lay on
representative Weber anyone else want to
be on that
we can settle it right now if we want
um
yes representative Merchant wants to be
on it I wasn't sure if representative
Nagel has spoken to whether he wants to
be on that okay or we can wait then
all right so I do please remember that
they're supposed to be
reporting oh sure
so we well we have three Democrats right
now so we need three Republicans
representative Weber oh I'm sorry I'm
sorry you're not a Democrat are you no
I'm not long ago
well I wasn't counting him yet I wasn't
sure that he was um definitely wanted to
be all right so yeah we need one more
Democrat and we need um
two more Republicans so okay we can talk
about that more one well if
we
we've already got three so we'll just go
to four that's fine too I mean I I don't
think it needs to be a huge committee uh
for
I'm sorry for my purposes what needs to
happen is we simply need to have a
formal committee subcommittee so that
notice can be put in the calendar of a
subcommittee meeting so that all of the
parties who are interested in that bill
can come and be heard all at the same
time so that we know that everybody's
getting their say-in and we also uh know
that it's being done in a timely fashion
and not hardly with sort of email
messages back and forth for this coming
upcoming calendar or
uh that's up to you Mr chairman um it
can be done for the upcoming calendar or
it could be done it depends on when you
want to hold our next meeting well I I
wanna I was thinking of continuing every
Wednesday until we get our work done
okay
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman I I'd make a suggestion then
for the subcommittee to wait until the
following week um so that everybody will
be able to be there and we can focus on
these bills um to figure out where we
are if any of the others need
subcommittees or not well my suggestion
would be that the subcommittee meets
well before the committee meets
so that we can get whatever we need for
an amendment
I mean it can't be the same day
so yes I I agree to that um what I was
saying was the other bills that we're
pushing forward the question would be if
we were going to look to schedule any of
those next week to work on them or if
we'd be moving further forward well but
the chair just said that we were going
to meet every week until we finished our
business so I thought that answered that
question
are you suggesting that we meet sooner
than Wednesday for the subcommittee on 2
40.
I'm suggesting first of all it has to be
calendared so we have to get it into the
calendar
uh if it's next Wednesday I can't meet
next Wednesday because I'm not going to
be here next Wednesday
um it could be from my perspective
earlier in the week or later in the week
and then taken up either that week or
um and that is one of the participants
on that I would be available Tuesday if
we could find time frame so maybe we can
although that I don't know if that's too
I'm not persuaded that I I think it
probably if everybody comes and speaks
their mind at that subcommittee as
opposed to later on I think I think we
could be done and I have made it very
clear that my own position is that if we
don't come to a very solid agreement
that satisfies everybody either for a
smaller piece or a larger piece that my
I would be willing to either retain the
bill or or
itl it all together
so I think that next week is fine and I
will I'm just checking calendar right
now
um that would be May 2nd yes that would
be May 2nd
um I'd be available after 10 o'clock
that day I too would be available after
10 o'clock that day maybe we should
we'll see about finding us a space for
I'm assuming that representative Leon is
going to be the first named on that
subcommittee yeah I would I would say
okay I would say
um we do we know if representative
Merchant representative Nagel do want to
you know he does want to serve right for
sure
and I think representative Nagel works
on Tuesdays he does
um I think maybe our next step is to see
if they can find us a room for Tuesday
while we see it the other members are
available the other thing is that you
could appoint a subcommittee of Two And
if other people want to help out
representative Nagel doesn't he
um does any
late in the afternoon there's even more
when they come back we can flush out the
membership when they come back
well yeah we can we can
Christine we can schedule a subcommittee
right and determine the membership later
all right why don't we do that then so
you said after 10 o'clock so we would be
available at 10 o'clock could we do it
at 10 30. sure because we have a nine
o'clock meeting and I don't know how
that's 10 30 sounds wonderful so far we
have a subcommittee of two and that may
be expanding but we'll we'll talk to the
other two when they get get here
okay
anything else on 240
all right let's move on to 263 then
um
I'll just open it up for discussion uh
obviously the the bulk of the discussion
the bulk of the debate
um it's focused on a sunset or no sunset
or along a sunset representative Leon
thank you Mr chairman I I
I recognize that this bill is almost
exactly what we passed in House Bill 2
except that bill has a Sunset and this
one does not the commission that is in
there is exactly the same in House Bill
2 everything except for either repealing
the chapter law that enables Medicaid
expansion
um or the two-year Sunset which we have
in-house Bill too so
um there's a couple different points to
discuss on this bill one is what's the
correct Sunset
um personally as far as I'm concerned
I'm pretty sure that that debate is
going to happen in the house bill to
budget discussion about where everybody
eventually settles on a Sunset date and
having two moving pieces at the same
time gets to be pretty complicated so I
personally like the idea of leaving the
sunset discussion to the budget there's
other issues too this bill brings a
permanent Medicaid expansion that uses
statute that includes sections that say
until this date in 2019 the department
shall so there's lots of old language
there's other language that right now
they're not able to enforce because they
had sought waivers at different times
there had been a ruling on the work
requirement and this unlimited Medicaid
expansion Bill really brings up the
question that we need to discuss what's
happening with this bill what this
program should actually look like
looking to update the language to make
sure that it actually reflects what this
state wants and not to just go ahead and
Roll It Forward for a very long time
period without bringing up these really
big and really important questions just
as far as one goes we've discussed with
the developmental disability Community
how important it is to be able to work
because when you work you participate
you build self-worth you you have a lot
of benefits that come from it and the
fact that we have the work requirement
now non-enforceable and Medicaid
expansion is a problem because
there are within that there is
exemptions when medically you can't work
or there's other reasons why you can't
work but your average person should
your average person should be would be
pursuing a job and a career and I'm
worried about this whole language about
your average able-bodied person should
be working when we're trying to make
sure that your average person who's not
quite as advantaged is also working but
it's good for all of us
so to be able to work to hold down a job
to have something that motivates you and
drives you forward so that that's just
one of the many areas I have several
different amendments that deal with
different aspects but I don't want to
monopolize this I just want to make sure
that we have a chance to discuss what
this bill would put permanently into law
with no Sunset and make sure that we're
representative Weber
[Music]
we held a very long hearing on Senate
Bill 263. well that was in 45 minutes
and if I counted correctly which I may
not have
uh 33 people actually spoke to us
and 34 people actually spoke to US 33 in
favor of the bill as it stood and they
and one person spoke against
the people who spoke in favor
represented a hugely broad Coalition of
business medical care providers Medical
Care recipients people whose lives had
been changed for the better
by the availability of Medicaid
expansion and so to say that there are
lots of problems with this bill
is to say that all of those people who
came and testified in favor of the bill
are somehow wrong and
what I heard
at the hearing was a very broad approval
of something which is in existence and
is working for many people the other
thing I heard is that
overwhelmingly that this is a bill that
allows people to get healthy enough to
be able to work more and then to be able
to
provide their own health care or get
Health Care on the exchanges it's not a
forever thing
it's it's the middle set of people who
tend to need help for a time either
because of a life crisis or because of a
medical crisis and it helps them get on
their way and get back to being a
productive member of society
if what you're defining productive by is
holding a job earning earning money and
paying taxes there are other ways of
being productive obviously so I think
that for us to say that the collective
wisdom of all of the people who
testified in front of us is wrong
somehow
and that we need to start over again
is
simply not the right way to go and I
would I would prefer to have the
committee pass the bill and pass it as
it is I think really the the discussion
is whether it is going to be the
two-year extension in the house budget
or whatever the Senate does with the
Senate budget but I would love to have
this committee and the house
firm that this is a program that has
changed people's lives and will change
people's lives going forward and that we
embrace it
representative Hull would you be hand up
I did thank you chairman
so I think there's a common goal for all
the members on the committee of taking
care of those who who need help the most
and
we need to be careful
when we use tax dollars
for people who
um
are are not permanently disabled right
because we're comparing taking care of
someone who's permanently disabled on
traditional Medicaid versus someone who
ran into a life event life event may be
something in terms of trauma to their
family something in terms of a job
change and they're in this transition
but if I understood the member from
Walpole correctly right 33 people
testified in favor but the last number I
saw was almost a hundred thousand people
on the program so as a percentage of
those participating in the program that
33 is a relatively small
um I would like to to explore things
that would help these people as they
transition out because unfortunately I
don't think we're seeing the trend we
all see this as a as a transitory
program there's a lot of people who are
staying on this program for much longer
periods of time and I think we need to
craft a program that helps people as
opposed to just supports people in the
terms of giving them something and and
leaves them at that state jobs are a
beneficial thing that was one thing that
was discussed earlier
um maybe it's a training issue maybe we
need to make sure that they have
adequate training and getting them into
the unemployment security is part of the
key element to getting them back on
their feet so there are definitely
things to explore
I will say representative oh I'm glad
that only 30 33 people came instead of
all right I might be a little off base
here but
um I know lots of people with college
degrees who have jobs but their jobs do
not hit full-time and it's because
companies can't afford to pay the
insurance so plenty of people who are
well trained educated and whatever are
kept under the 35 33 hours a week
whatever that would apply to full time
who who don't have insurance so and and
also someone who gets on if we authorize
this bill this doesn't mean that we're
as I feel an undertone here that we're
authorizing everyone who's on it now to
be on it the rest of their lives all of
these programs are our income based and
vetted either every one year or every
two years if Mr Lipman was here I would
ask him so
I'm at the hairdresser last week and um
they she working business whatever
husband and the trades they can't afford
insurance for them and pay for all other
things they need they have insurance for
their children and then the other
hairdresser binked around the corner
because we were talking about pet
insurance so both of them have pet
insurances for their pets but they can't
afford it for themselves so I I think
that to bring up this argument every two
years to bring you know when I first
came on the legislature five years ago
we were discussing the work requirement
for this which was uh cruel and and
ungainly for many people in New
Hampshire and when they tried to anyway
so I think we should pass this as is and
nobody wants people to be on
as some of you are kind of hinting at
like free government sponsored Health
Care forever most people as a
psychotherapist most people are happiest
when they're working when they have a
purpose in life and when they can and
their when they're self-sufficient and
this kind of a program gives people a
leg a foot a knee an arm up to be able
to get there and
um
I think we should pass it thank you
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman
um I would agree wholeheartedly with
what a few people said about the
importance of work
um
and um certainly for myself work has
been an incredibly important and um
fulfilling part of my life socially
um having a purpose earning money
feeling in in all ways and I would
encourage it makes me really sad when I
hear young people talking about work is
just something you gotta do
um
foreign
so I will say that I personally
um put in bills to repeal the work
um requirement in the current
um authorization
um because I saw it as a problem that it
was there but it wasn't it wasn't
implemented it wasn't in effect but
those bills
were defeated because
um
people who were interested in it in the
first place wanted to keep it in
um
the reason it was never implemented was
because of court cases where
um
first in Kentucky and here and then here
in New Hampshire and one other state
which I can't remember where it was
ruled by federal judges that Medicaid
was a health insurance program not a um
work training program or a character
building program so that the amount of
work that we were requiring
um
did not fit with
I guess what would what the courts
considered constitutional
um
I want to just throw into the
conversation here that um
70 of the people on Medicaid work
either part-time or full-time and I I do
believe it you know I think when we talk
about Medicaid in this committee I think
um
people some people
um think speak about it as a medical
coverage medical care for people who
can't afford Medical Care First
some people speak about it as something
that creates dependency first I'm
somebody who agrees that potentially it
can create dependency and that's a
problem
um but I for me that's way down the list
of what it does
um for me the fact that it provides
medical care that it keeps people
healthy that it gives them the
opportunity to go out and work it gives
them the opportunity to um
be full members of society that comes
way before the fact that it does create
dependency and I've been looking into
the fact about this issue of dependency
because I think it's something that we
struggle with as a committee and I want
to do something about
and so
um the way this is referred to is is the
the benefits Cliff you know what keeps
people from
going off state benefits or federal
benefits um and the fact that frequently
what people are going to lose if they
work more hours or work at higher pay is
so much greater than what they will gain
and that's that's a problem and I didn't
know this but there's actually a
committee within DHHS that's um that is
um has been created just to deal with
the benefits cliff and what what we can
change in
not only with Medicaid but all all of
the different kinds of Medicaid
all of the different kinds of benefits
food stamps um TANF all those things
what we can do to make policy changes
that would encourage people to move on
with their lives either by getting
education by getting higher paying jobs
by getting jobs if they don't have jobs
instead of being reluctant to do that
because they're going to lose out so I
think that is an important issue and I
think it is something that's I don't
know to what degree it's being addressed
but it is it's it's a recognized issue
that is being addressed which I would
think that maybe we as a committee in
the future can can play a part in
um
yeah
but I think this bill Medicaid expansion
um is not going to address that it's not
going to fix all the problems with
um with dependency with poverty
um you know when you think about it
poverty is one of the few
issues that we've seemed to have made
almost no progress with
um we
um we've made all kinds of scientific
advances we've made advances where
um you know people have all kinds of
material things like TVs and cell phones
poor people and wealthy people but the
number of people who live in poverty who
don't have who have trouble feeding
themselves and keeping themselves
sheltered has not really changed at all
and I think that maybe we can have an
effect on that if we work on this
benefits Cliff but I think in terms of
I'm rambling on a little bit I can't I
can't I can't I can't say I can't speak
as well as Senator Bradley who I think
spoke so eloquently about all the
reasons why this has been a tremendous
success why even if it's
reauthorized permanently there are guard
rails in the bill to protect us from all
of a sudden having to pay a greater
share of the um
expense for it
um
I think it's just been I just think it's
been a a success it hasn't solved all of
society's problems it hasn't so it
hasn't
um
it hasn't changed our you know some of
the basic dilemmas with health care but
I think it's been a tremendous success
in keeping people insured
keeping providers from having to
continually give out reimbursed care and
making sure that we have greater public
health and so I will definitely vote to
um
to vote for reauthorizing it permanently
thank you representative Leon thank you
Mr chairman I wanted to address one
small thing that I said that I think has
been misinterpreted I'm in speaking
about permanent or continuing Medicaid
expansion I wasn't talking about that
for the individuals but I was talking
about this relic of um of law that we
put into place in 2019 that is already
outdated continuing to be that vehicle
as people hopefully use Medicaid
expansion as a waypoint not a
destination as they get to other points
in their life while we support people
through this process
one of the reasons why I was perfectly
happy putting Medicaid expansion into
the budget with the two-year Sunset
um was because there are a lot of people
that I speak to that have Medicaid and
they have serious problems with the
program the way that they're accessing
it other ones as well there's there are
a lot of challenges even for people who
are using Medicaid right now there's
problems for providers who are providing
services that are reimbursed by Medicaid
and the idea of just having a relic stay
in statute forever now representative
Shapiro I really applaud your effort to
try and remove that work requirement
because the courts had voted against it
but this piecemeal approach to
addressing it doesn't really seem to
work because it's all together in one
basket and it's a matter of them looking
at which apples and which oranges are in
this basket as as we move forward and
that's one of the reasons I see value to
having a sunset I don't want to
monopolize a conversation I just wanted
to make sure that everybody under stands
that I do know Medicaid expansion is
supposed to be a waypoint and not a
destination representative McLean
thank you Mr chair
um I think everybody on this committee
uh understands that you know that we
have to
um renew the Medicaid uh expansion
because those things that used to exist
aren't there anymore and so to not renew
the Medicaid expansion at this point
would leave a lot of people out in the
cold I think the concern is just with
the Perpetual renewal
um one of the things you know if we look
at the Affordable Care Act the
Affordable Care Act came into play over
a decade ago and there were many
different pieces in the Affordable Care
Act that were supposed to work and we're
supposed to have price transparency the
exchanges health care costs are going to
come down we really didn't see a lot of
that the one thing at least on the
surface that did appear to work was the
Medicaid expansion and I think in many
ways because of that
Medicaid expansion became the victim of
its own success and we saw that a lot in
this committee this is my first time on
this committee but we saw Bill after
Bill after Bill uh let's add this group
to Medicaid let's add this group to
Medicaid you know because the perception
is that this this is the component of it
that's actually delivering the goods but
you know I wasn't here for the public
hearing
um I was off
um doing shingo training and when I was
off doing training one of the folks on
my shingo dream was a pediatrician from
Connecticut uh Dr Elliot Melendez so
he's uh he's a chief of pediatric
Critical Care in Connecticut Children's
Hospital so I said how you how you
making out in in Connecticut how are
things going and he said boys he says
Medicaid is killing us
he said now we are different than you in
New Hampshire I mean I'm in Hartford you
know Connecticut Children's in Hartford
so we're 60 Urban but you can imagine
with the reimbursement rates that we get
on on Medical Care on Medicaid
um we're just hanging on financially by
our fingernails and so I think in many
ways he may be a Harbinger for what we
may see here down the road we are not
Connecticut we are not an urban
environment like like they are
but we do have a quarter million people
in this state on Medicaid and that
number is growing that's almost one in
five people so I really do have concerns
um about the long-term Financial
viability and a long-term effect on our
hospitals um if we just let this thing
go without a revisit and the other thing
though putting the financials aside
representative Shapiro to kind of talk
about what you're talking about which is
the benefits cliff I think the benefits
Cliff is real when I first came to New
Hampshire over 20 years ago I came to
Nashua and I lived in Clock Tower Place
you may know what clock tower places now
this is a wonderful place it's it's it's
high-end it's a converted Mill Loft
Apartments great but all of my neighbors
were on social assistance you know some
Section 8 housing they're on Medicaid
Etc and so on and these were good people
these were not lazy people staying at
home
um playing video games these were good
people and these were my friends and you
know one of them a lady right next door
Mirna she had a job offer at a doctor's
office but she says Mark you know I
don't know what to do she says if I take
this job then I'm going to lose a lot of
my housing support and I'm going to lose
the coverage for my kids and she said
you know and instead of having you as my
neighbor I'm going to be living down in
the trees you know Ash Street Pine
Street at 7 and so on and so she she
made the decision ultimately not to go
forward and she wanted that job so bad
you know and so she's back she's working
on the table who am I to judge her is
she a bad person I don't think she's a
bad person she was a great neighbor she
was a wonderful lady and she was an
excellent mom to those kids so I don't
judge her but I do judge the system
that kept her from realizing her full
potential and so what we have in this
bill to address that is a commission and
this commission is going to meet and do
a report out once a year and you
mentioned as well something I was
unaware of within DHHS
but I really think that the commission
is woefully inadequate it you need to
have something that is looking at this
very actively and that just hasn't been
done yet so I would be much more
interested to you know see what that is
going to do see what DHHS is coming
forward in some of these areas
understanding that and then you know
leveraging that at some point in the
future to a permanent authorization but
the real thing for me is what's going to
push that I think is the stick I mean
we're all good people here in this room
and once this is made permanent we've
got opioid crisis we've got a housing
crisis we've got a homeless crisis we've
got a mental health crisis I see us
pivoting okay Medicaid expansion that's
dealt with for now and the stick isn't
there anymore and so we're focused off
on these other issues not because we
don't care about just a lot going on I
think the stick needs to be maintained
so that it's going to force to revisit
and that's why I think I don't know what
the nature of that final extension is
going to look like those error as
representative Leon said is it two years
four years whatever but I don't think we
should be going for a permanent
extension at this time uh thank you Mr
Medicaid expansion whether it's for two
years or six years
which would allow for more successful
procurement of Managed Care contracts or
permanent is not going to solve
some of the problems that you talked
about both in Medicaid in terms of
Medicaid rates although the our new
budget the house budget does have some
pretty extensive Medicaid rate increases
or the problem with the benefit Clips or
just how we address poverty and
motivation in general in our society I
don't
I don't I don't mean by any means to say
that
this bill is going to solve those
problems we have a lot of deep societal
problems that we have to continue to
in terms of providers
when I had a contract with the different
Medicaid was among the lowest payers for
providing Psychotherapy and it was a
problem it was quite low and I think
it's one of the things that results in
problems with Workforce shortage and I'm
sure it's a problem with doctors of all
kinds and hospitals
taking medicaid insurance
but consider what the alternative is
which is that they're not getting
reimbursed at all for that care and that
they are providing that care
as
unreimbursed care so I think that is why
we've seen the provider communities come
come in and say this is a very important
um
representative Nagel and then over here
I think I could talk all day on this one
um a couple years ago
um the American Bar Association the
American Medical Association sat down
and they came up with you know looking
at ethical issues for doctors and
lawyers it came to this conclusion that
we had a responsibility to care for the
people in need so they made a joint
recommendation that people that were
either in the bar where the AMA were
supposed to give about 10 percent of
their care to the poor that was great
um and then comes Medicaid and as you
know Medicaid was actually founded
because the healthcare Market was not
caring for the poor and the disabled and
it was a strategy because they were
being cherry-picked out of insurers to
cover them so
um that's why Medicaid was formed
initially and I remember talking to my
dad when he was when I was young he was
an anesthesiologist and he basically
came to the conclusion that it costs we
always forget that the only number in
business that matters is net revenue
it's not gross revenue it's it's net
revenue it's your your net gross revenue
minus costs but he said that he goes you
know what he goes we don't even Bill
Medicaid and we just do it for free and
it goes why is that because he said
because it costs us more to build
Medicaid than it does then we get back
so he says we might as well just do it
for free on satisfy Our obligation
I think one of the biggest sins in
health care in this country was the
death of Private Practice I think that a
lot of the issues that we're talking
about now like burnout and all these
other things would be are because
doctors have absolutely no control of
their environments anymore and and I
talked to hospitalists and people at
hospitals and they think Medicaid
expansion is wonderful it's great it's
wonderful I said in private practice
it's horrible I mean
we've gone from A system that we used to
be able to do what we thought was best
for our patients and granted that's
unlimited control in a blank check's not
a good thing but at the same time you've
gone to the exact opposite extreme and
what I can deal with with commercial
insurers is that I've got people that I
can deal with that I can interact who
question what I'm doing that I can talk
to and then do what I think I need to do
with Medicaid expansion that is totally
not true the people that make the
decisions for me are not experts in my
field they will make unreasonable
demands of my time for very little money
in return they will
um after they've denied my my request to
do a procedure they use evidence base
that's incredibly questionable at best
and there doesn't seem to be enough
transparency about that I talked to our
practice manager she said Medicaid
expansion is killing us and we also have
to realize that we're talking about two
separate things we're not we're talking
about you know Medicaid for a new group
of patients that were people that were
insurable before that are not now and
then we're talking about the poor and
disabled they're two totally different
groups of people
um but as far as I'm concerned if I I
I'm a private practitioner I'm one of
the last private practitioners left in
this in this state
and and to me um I would never work for
somebody else and
um and this is making my job harder and
harder and harder to do and the other
thing is the cost of me employing people
to deal with their denials their demands
when they're not paying me enough in
return to make it worthwhile that's a
real problem and I think that as we go
forward with our health care decisions
especially for people with complex
disabilities I look at Medicaid
expansion as a necessary evil and a
Band-Aid on a broken system the reason
why I think that there should be limits
10 20 years or whatever
is that I if you don't give people a
limit they will go on forever and I just
don't think this this program can
continue to grow unbridled and it needs
to have some oversight and some limit
that's enough for me representative
Murphy
thank you Mr chairman um
I think anybody that's practicing
medicine like Dr Nagel representative
Nagel has done could speak forever on
this and we would we should never do
that
um I haven't said that
um I was never in private practice I've
always been involved in a tertiary Care
Medical Center where we took all cameras
we were salaried we took all cameras and
that included probably two-thirds of our
book of business was Federal
reimbursement so he had Medicare which
people would say is pretty good that was
after sequestration that was cost minus
one percent and Medicaid which is about
50 cents in the dollar so yes the
reimbursement is not good but as others
have said some reimbursements better
than none because when you have a raise
or thin margin of one percent in a
hospital or a negative margin any funds
coming in to support the organization in
other patients that need that
organization is beneficial but I wanted
to speak to something else and
and I appreciate the the permanency
issue of this because
you're really speaking to the fact that
this if this is a broken system I would
always say we have really good health
care but you have a team which I would
rank as a plus in many circumstances
there are many great clinicians that
want to take good care of you
administratively across the country in
the state in the region I'd give us
probably a good d-minus as far as
operational you know uh running of the
show I get that and I've lived through
it on the other hand this is a really a
federal you've got to remember what
Medicaid is it's a federal program I
know it's shared by the state Medicare
is 100 Federal this is a shared program
it's Federal so when I look at the
permanency of this I'm thinking it's
permanent until the federal government
can come up with a better
you know Health Care Program for the
country and or the citizens in the
country so uh to me you know it's it's a
federal program in many ways and until
it becomes
um uh uh changed in some way by the
federal government I would vote for
permanency only because once the federal
government changes it gets rid of it
modifies it we can Will basically be out
of it
but I would also speak to one other
thing that you know you see regularly
with these patients is the psychological
uh benefit you know we can speak about
how it's good for Hospital reimbursement
to have something versus nothing we can
speak about the job force and if you
have a job you can have health care you
can get a job and be employed I
understand all that there's a lot of
arguments in favor of it but I would
argue about also the psychological
impact of having insurance and so you
would oftentimes see patients come in
with delayed care for whatever it could
be a large mass it could be you know
their hypertension you know we've seen
because of covet you know you don't have
access and have not had access
um appropriately for a lot of patients
because they were afraid to go in there
but
when a patient gets Medicaid they don't
understand that you're getting paid 50
cents on the dollar as a provider they
just don't get that they just know that
they are proud to have health care
insurance and they come through that
door thinking that they're going to be
treated as everybody else and they are
and so psychologically for many of these
patients it's a real advantage to have
health insurance because they really
feel like I am now contributing I have
health care insurance I'm paying you for
the service you give me and you know and
they're very happy and proud of that but
the other part of it the derivative
benefit of that is that we are seeing
patients that have insurance when they
need to be seen so if you don't have
health insurance you're not going to get
your routine colonoscopy you're not
going to get your routine mammogram
you're not going to get your routine
blood studies for whatever else you're
looking to to take care of your
hypertension meds so these patients
psychologically feel a tremendous
benefit having Medicaid and as a result
of that they are coming in to see you
they feel like they're contributing and
they are to some degree but they are
also getting good care in a timely
manner which when you think about it
down the road if you take care of a
problem now it costs you ten dollars you
take care of a problem that's missed
down the road it's going to cost
thousands of dollars so ultimately we're
going to lose out when we don't support
having health care for all is it a
broken system I don't disagree with you
on that should it be permanent not
permanent in the sense that you're
talking about but permanent in the sense
that as long as the feds keep this
program going we we should be part of it
as well and when they change it we can
then change it at that point in time so
I would clearly vote in favor of this
for a lot of reasons that go well beyond
what I just said and I took too much
time anyway so thank you representative
Cushman did you have your hand up
just thank you Mr chairman
um I also could speak all day about this
so I'm really trying to do that to limit
myself
um
I I really have to agree with a lot of
what representative Nagel said
um I see
a lot of um we've had the discussion in
here about bringing up the Health Care
system in New Hampshire and I see that
dependence on a Medicaid
largely
Medicaid based system a part of the
system being a huge piece of the pie
that makes up the payer mix being
Medicaid
um as on the one hand the reason that
the hospitals say that we can't free up
the Medicaid the system and then you
know
on the other hand
um
it's sorry I lost my train of thought
the issue is
um
it's putting pressure on the system
but they say that we need it
and
at the same time
it's limiting what's available
so to your point we can't have
non-profit hospitals here because you
have to accept all payments which means
Medicaid we can't have you know the
Cancer Centers of America come here
um there's uh it's putting a
a block on Innovation
um
you see that the care here is great sure
um there there are excellent hospitals
in this state and excellent and smart
and talented Physicians
um but at the end of it all not everyone
wants that kind of care that Medicaid
reimburses and so when you're making it
um they will you know you're expecting
that a big chunk of your patients will
only be able to receive a certain kind
of care you're not incentivized to
Branch out
the other issue is the work thing I
think we're incentivizing people to not
work in more than one way not only
because there's no work requirement on
this but we're actually with this
program subsidizing businesses where
they would otherwise provide for their
employees and I think that's why a lot
of businesses support this you know it's
a subsidy that people like free things
they like not having to have that
responsibility
um is there a reason that businesses
can't afford the insurance for people
well if there are there are regulations
in the way that make Insurance costly
let's get rid of them you know we need
to be making this more we need to be
opening up the system more and getting
to the root cause why is Health why is
Health Care first of all not affordable
and instead of relying on insurance to
make it affordable and give that peace
of mind just because you have a card in
your wallet
um people should feel good that they can
get health care and it can be affordable
with or without insurance
so I just see that there's huge systemic
issues that this doesn't resolve and it
just kicks the can down the road and
making it permanent is a huge mistake
because it's if anything you know we
have a very big Workforce shortage and
if we're just you know it used to be
that you'd get a good job to get
insurance you know you'd be like I have
to I have to have a job because I need
to I need to have insurance to cover my
family and now it's different so I just
see a a big mix of things playing into
this and
um
it's not sustainable
on the federal level with the debt and
everything else
you know the budget office saying that
well we need to decrease the roles and
we need to increase the share to the
state and that's good that that's in
there that you know we would sever this
program but would we really I mean that
would be devastating to a lot of people
to just stop it immediately you know
something would have to be done for all
those people you can't
it wouldn't be like instant
um
so yeah it's just a huge overarching
problem with this and there are specific
things in here that I
um I have a bunch of amendments to kind
of
trim some of the the issues that I find
in it
um
you know are people actually utilizing
it are they on it and not actually going
to the doctor because if they are we're
paying the mcos however much money per
day to administer you know a certain
number of people who are on it
but then they're not even using it I
don't know we shouldn't be paying
Administration on accounts that aren't
active you know what I mean
um
that's all I have for now probably have
more comments later
okay I'm trying
to think of things that haven't come up
first and the first thing that hasn't
come up is if we leave things as they
are in the budget in the house budget
uh a two-year extension is not enough
for competitive bidding on contracts
so that was one of the issues that came
up with respect to the shorter time
periods
um and so
at a minimum we need to have a longer
scope
then we get to the question of you know
nothing sharpens the mind like having a
hard deadline and having to do something
and I'm so glad we closed the salinity
Center 17 years ago or whenever it was
that we had the first heart deadline
because we've had plenty of hard
deadlines and the hard deadlines have
been in statute and every single time
we've run against the hard deadline and
the problem hasn't been solved so we've
extended on an emergency basis
um and I realize that that's comparing
apples to oranges but the stick doesn't
always work is my point here
um
to compare
to blame the existence of Medicaid for
the lack of Cancer Centers of America
for-profit hospitals in this state is
just a disconnect
plenty of states have Medicare Medicaid
and Medicaid expansion and if I said
Medicare before I'm sorry about that
because I
it's a big bug of mine and I'm my
apologies but if if
if we blame the existence of Medicaid
for the absence of these hospitals there
are states where uh Medicaid expansion
is in place in several Cancer Centers of
America
um there are two separate things and the
reason we don't have for-profit
hospitals is because we've voted it down
when it's come up
um
I think that one of the very the two
really oh one more point I wanted to
make was the
um Commission on Aging which I actually
set
um noting that in particular for people
of about 55 years and older who are not
yet Medicare eligible
um if they lose a job there's a huge gap
for them uh in terms of how are they
going to get coverage at a time when
they are more likely to need coverage as
opposed to the 20-somethings who are
less likely to need or use coverage
um I I did want to just refute the point
about you know not all 100 000 people
who were on Medicaid expansion came to
talk to us but the people who did come
to talk to us were a broad spectrum of
people like the business and industry
Association and and just saying that
business
ought to offer
um
health care for everybody
I love that as a notion but the fact is
that five years ago we didn't have
expanded Medicaid and business was not
covering these people and these
particular group were not getting
Medical Care and in particular and this
is the absolute bottom line for me that
we're not getting the preventive care
that they need to keep them out of the
more expensive
uncompensated care that is yet another
problem so
the preventive care aspect is really the
one that does it for me
thank you representative bull did you
ever end up earlier I did right and I
come at this having sat for the most
part for the last four months on
division three in finance discussing why
um expanded medicaid ended up you know
your microphone went off
thank you sorry I I commented this
having sat on division three in finance
the division that covers um HHS or DHHS
we spent a lot of time discussing
um adding expanded medicaid into the
budget the discussion of a two-year
versus a four-year versus an unlimited
sunset
to the point about you can't get
contracts renewed you're right they're
in a two-year extension right there is
no easy way to put that out for bid but
there is an easy way to turn around and
do an extension to an existing contract
so I don't know that that's a
non-starter I do think if this program
were to continue beyond that right a
longer time period is what you'd need to
put it out to the mcos
um regarding the for-profit profit
hospitals and Cancer Centers and and
other alternate types of treatment and
this is at some level to what Dr Nagel
or representative Nagel mentioned
um we should be encouraging alternate
Solutions
um for people who want to run private
practices for hospitals that want to
start up unfortunately current statutes
prohibit starting another hospital
within Manchester that is a for-profit
hospital or is a Cancer Treatment Center
or something that's a specialty for
um pick discipline of choice I guess so
maybe one of the things we need to do in
terms of tweaking the program is to
start to allow additional competition to
the system for those who want to expand
that
um
as a general rule we get what we reward
if we we reward people to be on the
program and we encourage that by giving
them benefits it will drive people into
the system we saw a huge uptick during
the covid crisis because we removed some
of the barriers to entry into the
program and in a very short period of
time it almost doubled in size
what may be a better thing is to figure
out how to incentivize people so there
isn't a step function I understand the
issues of Step functions as an engineer
so that they don't face the if I work an
extra hour or I change jobs I lose my
health care that's a real problem and
we've encouraged that problem by by the
statutes that we've set up
um to the member from Walpole right
preventative care is a much better place
to put money than it is in reaction to
health issues that have been delayed so
all of those weigh into it but just
pushing the program forward in another
two years four years five years six
years I've heard all sorts of numbers
unlimited doesn't solve the core issues
with the problem and I I mean I have
amendments we can introduce today if
we're going to come back I bring those
back but I believe there are all of
these elements need to be discussed in
the program
I saw a representative Merchant with his
hand
thank you madam chair
it's interesting to listen to the
conversation
what I'm hearing is three fundamental
things going on all the same time one is
we have a social problem
you have an economic problem we have a
systems problem
we're not going to solve the social
problem
with this bill
we're not going to solve the system
problem with this bill we have a
fragmented care
fragmented coverage lack of Standards
lack of portability
your health insurance unfortunately a
lot of times it's tied to your job and
it shouldn't be that way but that's
another societal issue
but we do also have something called
economics one of the things that caught
my attention
was when Senator Bradley was here
the impact has had in lowering health
care premiums for the employers
so the economic side of the equation has
really caught my attention
as far as the mcos to representative
polls
you're absolutely right if I was a
business owner and trying to make a bid
on the contract
and I don't have any Assurance or even
the intent for the legislative body
to have at least a five-year Horizon why
would I bid on a contract
if we don't have people bidding on the
contracts
the intent of us financially will be
significant
so therefore
at the minimum we have to have a
five-year Horizon
in reality Senator I mean a president
who ever said represent whatever
Department around here is a misnomer
I learned a long time ago in my first
term in the house
permanent is two years
because any subsequent legislative body
can change whatever the prior ones do so
the word permanent really is not
permanent it's only telegraphing if you
will to the marketplace our intent
is to make this at least long term to
allow for those who are out there the
mcos
to sharpen their pencils and bring it
back to us in a financial way it's not
going to go away
but if you want to be sure we have the
best contracts on the table I think it's
in front of us to ensure that we
Telegraph to the marketplace the intent
of this legislative body to make it for
at least five years I'd like to see it
for 10 years but that's kind of where
I'm coming from and number two the
workforce we keep forgetting about the
fact that when people are healthy and
get their care taken care of they
contribute to the workforce I've heard
time and time again
we have a Workforce crisis if we can
find ways to get people back into the
workforce
can help us become more productive
that drives the engine which drives our
economy so for all those reasons we
can't solve the social problems I'd like
to we can't solve the citizens problem
but we can definitely solve the economic
ones thank you
uh representative Shapiro and then
representative Nagel
um I just want to comment on this idea
that because we have expanded medicaid
that people
um
you know since we have it it's an
incentive to go on expanded medicaid or
Medicaid and then since it's difficult
to
um work and get the same benefits that
people don't go off of it and um
I'm not saying that's never a problem
um but I think the
um previous speaker prior to the
previous speaker referred to the
ballooning of the number of people on
expanded medicaid because they ease the
eligibility standards to get on Medicaid
and I think that's
not accurate the federal government made
a rule that nobody could expire for
Medicaid and therefore the numbers and
and there were a lot of people laid off
in the beginning of covid so all those
people even if they went back to work
um even if they were earning enough
money to no longer
um even if they didn't fill out the
paperwork to get renewed
um by federal law couldn't be expired so
the number did go up from
sure Mr Littman knows but something like
from sixty thousand or fifty five
thousand to ninety thousand that's true
and that's being addressed right now and
people the number will go back down and
so it's not because people
saw an opportunity to go on the Dole and
they went on the Dole um it was a
federal ruling that we had no control
over so there were
temporarily more people on expanded
medicaid
make one observation that we should
really be proud of um I looked at
Medicaid participation rates Medicaid
Medicare Medicaid in the United States
and actually New Hampshire is number one
we have about an 87 percent Medicaid
expansion rate which is or part Medicaid
participation right it was pretty
amazing
um with that said I think the reason why
I would like to see a 10-year thing or
whatever is this
Medicaid on especially managed Medicaid
really unnecessarily increases our costs
and getting representative Murphy what
you what I'm kind of getting back to is
a lot of the Medicaid patients I see I
know they're going to cost more than I
get so you know I do I just don't even
charge Medicaid I don't even bother it's
not worth my time energy or Hassle and I
just don't think it should be that way
but I do think there's there's some very
simple fixes that maybe this commission
can do to improve the way that they
interact with us as doctors as all the
commercial insurers do they can use them
as role models and they can decrease our
unnecessary costs and make this product
project more viable but I did want to
point out one other thing these are two
absolutely wonderful documents that I
kind of think I talked to people one
year is the New Hampshire 10-year Mental
Health Plan and the other ones the
governor is Commission on Alcohol and
Other Drugs and the really beautiful
documents like representative Miracles
call your doctor again represent a
merchandise I have basically fixed the
entire Health Care system for people
with chronic pain we did at today while
you were doing whatever you were doing
um
um but basically what we did was we
outlined a system and that's what these
two things do and prevention is a huge
element
um
um in this and and that's important but
then they come to the conclusion is that
their primary payer mix is Medicaid and
with Medicaid they cannot cover their
costs and they cannot do whatever they
need to do so the critical thing is yeah
Medicaid needs to be important part of
what we do going forward but we do need
to accept that at some point is too much
that our systems will not survive our
health care providers will not provide
if the payer mix goes over a certain
percentage and we really need to
understand that as we go forward and not
just talk about extensions and things
like that but also talk about limits
there I'm done
uh representative McLean
thank you uh Madam chair so I I think
you know representative Merchant you you
are correct what is prominent I mean
permanent may be just the next
legislature but if we look at history
um Medicaid was expanding was brought in
in 2014 for two years nobody talked
about it until the two years and then it
was extended again until 2018 for two
years nobody talked about it again for
two years then we brought it in in 2018
for five years and it went silent the
debate went silent until the five years
so
based on history I understand the
permanence is relative within the
legislature but based in his based on
history the discussion flares up at at
those terminating points and so I think
everything that representative Murphy
said is correct there's value in having
some compensation versus nothing there's
value and understanding that I have
insurance so that you know I can go in
and not avoid care all those things and
the reduced costs to the employees that
you talked about there's value in all
these things but you know again we're
supposed to be looking at the health
care as a whole Mosaic and if you heard
the comment from representative she's
talking about her her hair stylists you
know these are working people and they
said but they need Medicaid because the
exchanges just aren't working for them
and realistically long term
um we need to to have that working I
know in this committee we heard a whole
bunch of testimony and as part of
orientation on Medicaid I didn't really
hear anything about how the exchanges
work there's a lot of siloing I think
going on with respect to you know I
don't know if the Commerce Community
really understands a lot about the
Medicaid part we certainly don't
understand a lot about the exchanges but
all of these discussions have to happen
and I think you know we need to
understand what these fixes are
before we can go forward and say yeah
this is it and so I understand your
comment about permanence but for me
history tells a lot about what the
problem is going to be and if we extend
this thing indefinitely as I said we're
going to move on to other things is my
fear and so I think it's it's really
time time to time to hold back on on the
permanent for now I I still believe that
thank you madam chair representative
Seth King thank you madam chair
I wasn't originally gonna say anything
because you guys already know how I feel
about all this stuff but
um I'll just make a few points
um that I've come up with by listening
to everybody even the U.S military
budget isn't permanent every couple
years they have to go back and get a
renewal so if they have to get a renewal
every two years I think so should
um so should this and to address
representative Merchant's point about
permanency
um you're right that we can't bind a
future governing body but there's a
caveat and that is in order to end this
program in the future it would take it
would take the agreement of the house
the Senate and the governor it would
take all three bodies to agree to end it
or even change it whereas if we do it
piecemeal then if there is a problem
with it it would take it would
incentivize those bodies to work
together and make the changes or if one
body couldn't come into agreement the
program ends so that's that's how the
the permanency does make a difference
when it comes to that it requires all
agreements all the time whereas
if it's if it's not permanent anyways
already explained that um so
um if the entitlement is permanent
um people will internalize that and they
will act accordingly
um if there's an entitlement that they
think might go away they're going to
think to themselves well I can't get too
comfortable because it can go away so I
need to take care of myself but once it
becomes permanent people
um respond to incentives and they'll
think to themselves oh I got it made I
don't need to work too hard to become
self-sufficient
um and then a question I have is what
percentage of people would be too many
people to have on Medicaid can anybody
answer that for me and will it
permanently
um in expanding the Medicaid will that
increase the number of people on on the
Medicaid and then a couple last points
and that is to address another thing a
representative Merchant said we could
fix the economic problem of Workforce
shortage really quickly if we got rid of
all of the entire entitlements because
you would find people coming out of the
work all of a sudden willing and able to
work I guarantee it and then lastly
people are always talking about how hard
it is to live and I think that if you
are a net taxpayer it is becoming
increasingly hard to live but when I
look around and I see obesity epidemics
and drug abuse problems I'm thinking to
myself life has become too easy it's too
easy if we can sit around with all of
this Leisure Time and even the poor
people I know have expensive expensive
cell phones and TVs and cars and Leisure
Time I'm thinking to myself it's way too
easy get these people back to work get
them off the drugs stop them from
sitting on the couch and eating
themselves to death so yeah I don't
think what we need is more entitlements
I think we need to get rid of all that
stuff and you will automatically see
people become self-sufficient I promise
thank you representative Tellez you had
your hand up yeah hi
thank you and there's no that's shared
here and I don't have a lot of
as much off the top of my head as I did
when I worked at the Department of
Health and Human Services
um but I don't really know people who
are sitting around and that's why
they're obese right we have issues with
food security with the quality of food
that's available that's affordable
um that
um they're busy working two jobs and so
they don't have time to go for a walk or
the neighborhood they live in is not
walkable for a variety of reasons and so
we're talking about a lot of complexity
and I appreciate that someone broke out
there's many many problems that were you
know thinking this one bill is going to
fix and that's not realistic so you'll
recall the reason we had the affordable
character in the first place was because
Insurance being one of the most
profitable Industries in the country was
making it so that employers couldn't
afford to cover their workers anymore
and people who worked couldn't afford to
uptake insurance that was offered to
them and these are people who work often
more than one job and so I think that um
I agree with the comment that was made
that a lot of people who represent a lot
of the hundred thousand people who are
covered came and spoke before this body
and provided a lot of information about
how this has really helped New Hampshire
we had an opiate crisis we were
embarrassingly number one in the country
or number two in the country for opioid
deaths like that was horrible and
Medicaid expansion provided behavioral
health coverage in a way that had not
been provided previously it's allowed
people to at least have a minimum
Assurance to be able to get care when
they need it you know hopefully yes
there's issues with getting in but
hopefully have some ability to take care
of their health so they can work people
want to work I've always worked in
places where people struggle they want
to work they need to be able to get care
if they need it and not be straddled
with as we remember previously also
being bankrupted by Health bills which
is also another significant problem and
so um
uh I just want to go ahead and Echo that
I agree that that there's been a lot of
good thinking and information provided
as well as data provided about how this
has benefited New Hampshire it's made us
have a stronger
economy it's provided for a stronger
Workforce and taking it away will just
make things worse and not better and
agree that you can't contract out this
issue of trying to issue contracts for
um uh you know whoever will be the
vendors just is impossible if we don't
at least have a reasonable time Horizon
thank you representative Merchant
thank you chair
the answer to representative King's
comment how many people in Medicaid is
too many
I'd say one because what that means is
as a society we're not providing them
the opportunity to do it themselves
which means you're probably not employed
appropriately they're probably working
what are called corporate welfare
working for
companies that pay them a minimum wage
and therefore we're subsidizing at
minimal wage which is what I call
corporate welfare
and also would remind people
and every single barrel whatever we're
looking at there's always going to be
five or ten percent of those people in
that Barrel that don't belong there
rotten apples
however and I'm not going to take the
whole barrel and throw it out because
the five or ten percent in there that
are rotten
just because I want to get rid of the
five or ten percent there's ninety
percent of the people probably 95 of the
people
that don't really want to be there but
they have no choice but to be there so
from society point of view I'll remind
people that it's not looking at it
strictly in the end of the five or ten
percent and trying to figure out how to
eliminate that
without understanding we're having an
impacting of the 90 to 95 percent
so yes one is probably too many because
it's an indication from our society
that we are not giving those people the
opportunity
that they deserve to earn a living
for them to be off the system
so those are my comments though
representative Nagel
um I just I'm going to talk and
supportive people on Medicaid um there's
um it's kind of like a lot of other
things socially you can't look at them
as a homogeneous group of people it's
very heterogeneous and the people that
I've looked at are taking care of most
of my career people with severe
disabilities spinal cord injury head
injury you know people like that that is
really disabled and and they need this
to survive on um that's another long
story
um but like the Medicaid expansion
program what it did
was it gave Insurance to a whole group
of people that didn't have enough money
to afford insurance
um weren't getting it through their
workplace but most almost all the
Medicaid patients ICM Medicaid expansion
actually are working and some of them
more than one job so I don't think we
have to really remember like who we're
talking about
I I did want to answer your one question
because I don't know what the answer is
but um I would be very uncomfortable if
more than 10 percent of my payer mix was
Medicaid
um I I think once you get over that
number you're you're really starting to
strain your resources
um and I would really like to work with
the Medicaid managed plans to figure out
a way to cut their demands on us that we
can cut our costs so maybe we can see
more than that but right now it's not a
functional system
another discussion
representative Palazzo
uh we hear a lot that this bill won't
fix all problems but I think we are
focusing on financing too much and uh we
need to focus more on science-based
medicine and it's a lot of financing
more than a half a billion dollars on
the table and we are getting too excited
when we hear that 90 percent of it will
come from federal government so we don't
have pay for it but on one hand like
somebody still have to pay for it and
it's aspects press but also it comes
with a lot of
strengths attached so when we talk about
lack of Standards
it's a part of it it's another Federal
program that is expanding and sometimes
it's not is the best
uh policies that goes along with it and
part of it might be regulatory caption
but also it could be just uh things move
slowly on federal level and
like for example with uh
adaptations like New Hampshire
dietitians maybe already up to current
science but they have to abide to the
federal uh whatever it's called board
that is very slow in implementing uh
signs that is changing so I I think
we are trying to implement work
requirements for participants and it's
good but excuse me my language I think
we need to do work requirement on
ourselves let's work on amendments for
this bill because
there are some problems that we can try
to solve with this great vehicle and
otherwise some problems like higher
prices less prices like all this muscle
like 50 cents on one dollar compensation
yeah it doesn't help
our medical clients as a whole thank you
Mr chairman we we have
spoken
theoretically and extensively
um we have spoken globally and
specifically
uh and all of us have edited our
comments because all of us could speak
my question is what are we going to do
now
um I are are we going to vote on
amendments today do we want to give
people more time to bring amendments uh
are you done
what exactly are we going to do going
forward
because we're not going to solve alleles
of society and we have a bill in front
of us
and we have a process
and I'm just trying to figure out what
your plan is for us
going forward or are we going to deal
with this today are we going to deal
with it
at a later date what what's the plan
sure it is an early bill as one might
expect
um and there are several amendments
representative Merchant has one
representative Cushman has a few I guess
and it looks like representative Leon
may have a couple uh so I I'm
we we're going to be meeting next week
uh I suspect we might even be meeting
the week after I guess it's one week at
a time uh so I'm I'm willing to I'm
I'm sensing that we're not ready to
really dispose of this bill today that's
my sense but I'm open to input from the
committee I want to I want to consider
everybody's
position and I'm thinking continue until
next week but representative you had
your hand up I would love to be able to
read all the amendments in the quiet of
my home
um so I I would enjoy if we could have
all the amendments to take home with us
tonight sure and and that makes sense
representative Leia
um thank you um some of it is that this
is complex because I have one where it
just says to repeal one certain line of
it but the the rationale behind it and
the reasoning behind that I don't know
if anybody's gone and taken a deep dive
into
rsa126-a which is the statute that is
our Granite Advantage plan but that is
a mess to put it nicely but if I if I'm
at home I can look up that RSA and read
it at my leisure to try and make sense
and then at least if I can read all
these ahead of time I can come in you
know knowing what this is about further
explanation would help but
um I have trouble reading when it's
noisy when everybody's talking whatever
I can just take this in much better if I
can read it in the quiet of my home
given the importance of this issue we
need to consider every
option and every learning style every
aspect of it and the direction of it I
think so
representative Shapiro
I'm as guilty as anybody as of going on
and on and being philosophical about
these issues but I think as we get into
the Amendments I think I would
appreciate it if we had kind of a more
structured
um
kind of debate and then vote
um I don't know whether that's being
time limited or people just paying
attention to be really focused on what
they're saying that it's directed
directly at the amendment before us but
we had some unstructured time some of
our members had a meeting that they had
to attend and we we didn't want we'd
agree we would not have any you know any
votes during that period so that was
part of it
going forward I think that would be
perfect absolutely that's and that's how
usually we we have proceeded
I appreciate uh and my thankful for
those who give the Amendments uh
amendments ahead of time for us to read
it but at the same time some amendments
they they are based on how discussion
will go and uh what other amendments
already submitted so
um I would ask to allow all sorts of
amendments
like to submit them when they feel it's
appropriate
oh people can meet them ahead of time
they can write down questions and meet a
more meaningful discussion I think
um did you yeah go ahead representative
Leon thank you Mr chairman part of it
too is that depending on how this all
evolves I have some that I may not even
offer and I don't want to inundate you
with all of these different points if
there's some points that there's no that
that there's no appetite for because
instead of trying to put it together and
deal with this big wildly bill
um in one Amendment I'm trying to
address each of the different points and
this is one where as we go on and have
this conversation it's one of those
where it's very intertwined
and um so that that's why I just have a
little bit of a reluctance of just
sending all of these different
amendments and number one I'm waiting
for still for drafting from OLS on some
of them
um and it's a process in order to do
this because they do need explanation
when they're introduced
representative Weber
nobody can make anybody else share an
amendment if they don't want to share it
it's privileged until you offer it to
the committee so
um perhaps we could take under
advisement representative matter upham's
request
that
I know I am very much in her Camp I
would be much more likely to look
favorably on an amendment if I've had
time to read it to think about it to
look up the statute
and perhaps to ask questions of the
sponsor if I have them
um
but
you know people can do whatever they
want to do and
I don't see that we have a lot of
control over it well let me ask this
question does anyone object those with
amendments sharing them if they so
choose and we can
I was at all or nothing it's just like a
we can't enforce no no I know I know but
if somebody wants to share an amendment
okay
is there any objections is there any
Mr ship yes representative Hall
um
so in light of what we discussed this
morning relative to RSA 1449 and in
preparation for a potential amendment
that hasn't been drafted do we also need
to change the makeup of that committee
as well
and is that something we should be
looking at having someone draft ahead of
time
no no no no on 263 there is a committee
made up of various people but the
legislatures are not in the majority do
we need to address that to be compliant
with RSA I would say uh representative
Weber
I think our researcher oh I'm sorry
here she comes
yes
so that Clause that says now I'm
standing 1449 has been a work-rounded in
the middle that is what people notice to
get a commission that is not the new
team that was put in the 2021 we hate it
but it's legal yes so it does not have
to be a joke and it's the purview of I
mean we're trying with the community of
commissions
um to try and keep it
um building but it's not like it's it
would pass the way it was it's it's a
problem for us but it's not illegal it's
not so we do not need a statute no you
don't
um although they try to enforce it but
that's a word So based on practice and
legal opinion
the drafting attorney like that's just
what they've been doing it's it's one of
those loopholes that we're trying to
goals but have not so if that makes
sense like it's nothing necessary
um with all you have going on it's not
necessary if you wanted to do it I just
feel like it would bring that a lot more
work to hear
thank you
apparently we do not need to uh we do
not need to take care of that
representative Hall apparently there's a
there's a loophole involved that they're
working on closing but it's not
something we need to do so
thank you representative Leon uh thank
you Mr chairman um but however if we
feel that it's good policy to not give
notwithstanding a certain RSA that was
designed to control this type of uh
creep of um commissions from being a
legislative effort to one that's more
Community Based
um that if we believe that we should
stick with the intentions of RSA 1449
then it would be a good idea to draft an
amendment and to do that I guess the
question is how many amendments do we
want to consider
all of the ones that are necessary to do
our work that's fake enough
representative whoever
I am recalling a committee where there
okay I hope we don't beat the record
um other discussion
all right so uh I
will continue to 40 to next week is that
a fair I mean
263 rather
Mr chairman this question of the makeup
of the committee on 240 while you're
around right it's currently consists of
Representative layout in Excel right
there's two members and representative
Merchant I hear you might want to be on
that
okay very good representative Nagel
you're busy on Tuesdays still as I
uh there's a meeting at what time 10 30
next Tuesday were we able to secure a
[Music]
Senate Bill 240. Mr chairman we have we
have usually in this committee allowed
members who are not members of a
subcommittee to sit in and
participate they don't participate in
the voting but
next Tuesday
I
no I'm I'm suggesting that if we have
two people already and other people are
sort of wanting to participate around
the edges they're welcome to do so I I
don't understand what you're talking
about about an email oh to know exactly
what time these have to go in the
calendar
so you read your calendar and the
calendar says when it's meeting and what
room
um okay and again I I do representative
way on
um thank you Mr chairman um this is one
of the areas that is I think entirely
non-partisan
um I actually would really like to see a
subcommittee of myself representative
Weber and representative Merchant if
there's no one else wanting to join us
that's fine but
um I I I think we do need to look for
all three of us to be available so if
representative Merchant isn't available
on Tuesday
um I know we have we'll meet on
Wednesday we'll have session on Thursday
we'll probably need to sleep on Friday
to recover so it may be able to go into
next the following calendar
does that work with you yeah could the
other option could we possibly meet on
Wednesday before this meeting no no
okay thank you
okay so are we prepare to notice a
meeting right now or just push it off to
the next calendar I think we'll notice
it in the following calendar
all right so I won't be it won't be in
this calendar okay
um any other business to come before us
today I I met um representative Leon I'm
not sure what everything that may have
happened while I was gone earlier but um
we had skipped over our Senate Bill uh
239 because
um I think our two most knowledgeable
two of our more knowledgeable committee
members on that had to go to their other
meeting so I think that
um it would be good to see the
Amendments that Representatives Nagel
and Merchant that representative Nagel
has on Senate Bill 239 and to consider
that even if we do end up continuing it
that would be my advice I don't know
what you'd like to do no that's fine
enjoy
just just trying to get caught up on
when I was when we talked about it
briefly in the hall but yes lots of
moving pieces today representative
Shapiro I just want to get some clarity
I I have another meeting to be at so are
we are we not going to exec any more
bills today or are we
well I I was thinking of a thing where
239 ends up going but um you have you
have to leave well I'll I'll stay if it
if I I just needed to know okay
um I mean representative Nagel has three
amendments so I I guess we have to
we've continued so much today I I would
hesitate to guarantee we will accept for
other girls but uh what what we were
told when you were out of the room was
that there was more discussion to be had
even Beyond these amendments so
um
I you know I was one who came thinking
that we were actually going to do all of
the bills
today and then and then you know I think
I think we're at a point of diminishing
returns frankly and we have till the
11th for two of the bills and we have
till June 1st for the rest of the bills
so I mean I'm you know in the in respect
to representative Shapiro's schedule I'm
happy to
representative Weber is the ranking
member of I'm happy to defer any further
votes today if
if
we were told that there were more things
that needed to be done with 239 in
addition to what's being passed out now
and representative Leon is nodding her
head so I think she's one of the people
who wants to do more with it so I don't
see how we can vote on it today okay and
we have plenty of time so
perhaps coming back when we're all fresh
is
and and have read as much as people are
willing to share uh might be a good idea
that's fine we'll defer any further
can we also defer any further discussion
or are we going to have more discussion
well I
um representative Nagel is there
anything you want to say about these
amendments that you want to give people
a chance to read them and
um microphone
sorry
um
I I if I could just advertise them up
front two of them are extremely basic
um but the one that's the most important
or the most challenging is on the whole
definition of harm reduction and should
this be in the bill or not because the
word harm reduction is not defined in
statute anywhere
um so I've only been saved too by the
way the third one no there should be a
third one coming around okay I haven't
that third one hasn't made it yet so
um
thank you I'm sorry to interrupt you no
it's all right I mean there's there's
three amendments the first one as you
quite are aware of now I was very
concerned about the changing of the word
of abuse to misuse and how that could
adversely stigmatize people in pain that
actually have legitimate use for these
medications so
um mizo Higgins and I um sat down and
crafted a statement that would allow
them to be accepted from that definition
um when um Senator Waters brought up the
bill originally he had a CME requirement
for doctors he was not aware that it
already existed in rules so what we did
was we just took what he wrote exit
output in what's in rules and actually
what's in rules is substantially more um
difficult than what he recommended and
then the third one is um there again the
whole issue of harm reduction is very
important for several people in this
room and I
um uh Senator Waters came up with a
recommendation for defining that so I'm
I'm submitting that on his behalf
great thank you
are there any questions initial
questions on any of these I realize many
of you want to read them and review them
and perhaps do some research before we
get into them in more detail but any
preliminary questions right now for
representative Nagel representative Leon
thank you Mr chairman and representative
Nagel in light of some of my recent
personal events I'm just curious if
there should be any protection for
people who are end of life as well as
chronic pain patients so that they can
get appropriate pain management if there
if we're more worried about their either
ease of suffering while trying to
survive versus an addiction that they'll
never live long enough to see yeah
that up I I was hoping that that um the
the one the thing we came up with would
accept them from that would be
sufficient but see what you're thinking
if it's not we should talk about it I
mean it's like a huge issue um
this whole concept of opioid refugees
when we met with the speaker that was
one of the issues that came up but we
asked me 15 million Americans benefit
from long-term opioid therapy and about
90 percent of them can't get access to
it so guess where they go because they
either commit suicide they go without or
they go to the streets to get it and
we're seeing a rise in an unacceptable
rise in suicide and people with chronic
pain
um end of you brought up end of life
care and I know you have a personal
experience with that and so do I and
it's just we're actually seeing adverse
palliative and hospice care now so it's
extremely important when we when we go
through these bills that we make sure
that that group of people does not
adversely affected by this so
um I mean that that's kind of My Hope
and that we need to make sure that that
language gets perfect so if it's not let
me know and then let's make sure it is
now that I know how to make an amendment
that's a dangerous skill for you to have
prior representative Weber
I just wanted to add my voice to that
concern I had simply assumed that when
we were talking about pain management it
would also adequately cover end of life
issues but
um one of the fortunate things about my
late husband's illness was it happened
from 1996 to 2000 when people were
willing to prescribe him Limitless
numbers of msir 15 so he could just take
exactly what he needed when he needed it
and didn't have to worry about either
having a continuous medication which
kept him hazy and sick
when he didn't need it and
we were lucky then and I know that that
doesn't happen now and I am hoping that
we can get back to the point where end
of life care really is something that
um we honor and help people deal with
their medications in the way that works
best for them because some people do
need the higher levels and higher Doses
and continuous doses but some people
really didn't and and I know I would
never have have the number of pills that
I had on hand in the house now
and the only mismanagement we ever did
for those Hills was that the disposal
method at the time was you flush them
down the John so I am responsible for
many eight-legged frogs in the lower
Connecticut River Valley and I'm really
mortified about that but the care was
really good care and we need to go back
to it you'd both bring up a really super
important point because one of our
stakeholders is New Hampshire hospice
and palliative care organization I've
worked with them for a long time and
actually my origins in medicine were end
of life care so with these are all
important issues to me but one of the
things that we have been able to do very
successfully so far is except
um end-of-life care from a lot of the
statutes that we've done
so so far we've been really successful
the problem may be that you know I've
seen if you get the wrong person in the
wrong place at the wrong time you can
screw that up
so it may be important that we do
specify that um I think if you know the
more I think about it that is a good
idea that we rate that specifically
thanks for bringing that up that's
really helpful representative
thank you Mr chairman I just passed out
one of the Amendments I had several but
one of the ones that um is eligible to
discuss please note that on line 14 the
word and needs to be replaced with or
the goal here was simply that if people
are on this program right they're either
seeking help to get training this is
part of this transitional thing or
they're working not both minor drafting
issues so it's not ready to submit with
another discussion
we uh we did we did actually do we did a
lot today we we made it and I'm serious
about this we made it through four bills
we had some really good discussion on
others so we'll be continuing on the
other five until next week now the ones
we did complete today were Senate Bill
85 Senate Bill 87 Senate Bill 171 and
Senate bill 238. so
um
right I mean not that we can't um do
anything with it but yeah there's a
subcommittee so representative Leon um
thank you Mr chairman um I think if you
may remember last week I had objected to
the harm reduction language
um in my Minority Report I do have
language about drug checking stations to
make sure that Fentanyl and Xylitol
which is the trunk can be identified
both so that users aren't having
unwanted adulteration and so that our
Public Safety and our Public Health can
understand what's on the streets I've
spoken with a former former chairman of
the police Chiefs Association around
that so I will distribute it to
everybody I think that that narrows it
down to a pressing need
um and so I'm hopeful that I'll have
some support on that I just wanted to
mention that because that's part of the
same harm reduction we're looking at but
it's just narrowed in because of the
challenge of the definition so is that a
floor Amendment then for the that bill
it's the minority Amendment so it'll be
in the calendar but yes it's one that's
on the floor okay thank you
that's fair
any other discussion on it's it's either
a minority Amendment or it's a floor
Amendment if it's a minority Amendment
and in the calendar it's a minority
Amendment not a floor Amendment thank
you for that four amendments are always
in the seat Pockets right usually
usually yeah
any other discussion on any of the
business before the committee on these
bills
if not we'll adjourn until 9 30 next
Wednesday thank you you know what's fun
today
so I I was obviously my friend in Dallas